wow great up hello people of the world
and Beyond people of the universe who
are watching and the multi-dimensional
uh Multiverse hello to everybody hello
God what's up what up uh today is our
very last episode of the year in
studio that's crazy all of our hard work
uh
and planning is culminating together on
Sunday for our
huge final show of the year the steamies
which is going to be such a show it's
going to be a day to remember and it's
going to be sexiest YouTube sexiest
night of Year sexy as it's going to be
such a fun show it's going to be so
great the guys the crew have put in so
much dang work into this thing it is
going to um I got to say I'm it's very
impressive I think what we put together
well let's see first but I just hope Sam
makes it alive Sam has been going nuts
every day something is broken her
shoulder her finger her finger did we
talk about the finger thing on the show
yeah she came out and was like I have my
finger I have my funger in my pocket and
then worst of all this today she had a
spray tanning
accident I don't think it's that bad but
no she just hasn't washed it off yet she
got to wash it off yeah it's jarring at
first but then you glow yeah exactly
exactly it's just blackface for half a
day it's not just half a day it's I know
I'm kidding she not she's not even close
to blackface not even close uh today's
episode is sponsored by gamer subs thank
you to them also this episode is
sponsored by ducky here's our new Yorkie
puppy he is so sweet so cute this is his
first time in the studio he was born
August 22
makes what's today almost 4
[Music]
months almost 4 months oh we got a duck
sound
nice and he's got to be the
cutest the cutest puppy of all time he
is his face is so freaking cute and he's
just he's such a great dog so far I mean
he's got such a great
temperament um he's not
fussy he's just really
happy which bothers Alfredo yes Alfredo
is being such a grouch and he just wants
to play and be with alfredo it's all he
wants he loves Alfredo Al but Alfredo's
always like like anything if he just
gets close to him he's
growling but he's warming up he is
warming up we'll get
there we'll get there you know Alfredo's
been through a lot so I get it and now
we've got this little shrimp soaking up
all the
attention you
know I heard you say that you won the
birthday Olympics and you really did I
think that's my best birthday oh you
heard that I ever thank you I did
it I did it thank you to Lena too she
was a big help yeah but yeah we did it
we did it I just I we had such a fun day
already so I was like okay this is
awesome wasn't expecting anything else
to happen afterward I was just I was
just thinking about the puppy the whole
day I did see that you were so excited
to get back home and I was just thinking
what could it
be yeah I told you it's um it was like I
have one small thing at home and I was
it was he is quite small so I was
technically being truthful about
that um but anyway we have a really fun
show here today guys we've got Matt re
drama PowerPoint everybody is Lov loving
hating on Matt R uh so that's going to
be a lot of fun he's been in all kinds
of
shenanigans he deserves all the hate he
does kind of you know he he does
actually and that's what's so fun about
it that's why people are loving hating
absolutely our very own Tana Mojo was
actually involved in a new Matt R
Scandal which is pretty
exciting he treated her best friend
Brooke and podcast co-host so horribly
oh my
God it made me so mad to listen um I
should I'll I can't wait to hear about
that I'm going to warn you guys up front
we're going to do about two hours today
because we again have a lot of work to
do in preparation for Sunday there's a
massive truck in the parking lot mhm um
and so we want to just make sure
everybody's got the time to do what they
got to do but I promise you Sunday night
at 700
p.m. you you are going to be
experiencing a full sexiness that
YouTube has never seen before A Night to
Remember
um so yeah that's just up front right
there so we got Matt reif we've got
um Mr be sued for these nuts we've got
the end of the year Bingo predictions we
made we do that every year we make
predictions mhm and at the end of the
year we see how did our predictions line
up okay so we're going to go over that
together which is fun and then also who
could forget pornhub's year in review
which I always love looking over mhm
um and uh I forgot about those which
ones the PornHub oh yeah every year you
get a li no peek into which which state
is watching the most Lolli porn or
whatever uh turned red
anyway also it's the last time I have a
chance here here you want to hold
this it's the last time chance I have a
opportunity to tell you guys to go to
Teddy fresh shop the new collection it's
a perfect gift for the
holidays and the new collection is
outstanding uh Teddy fresh.com go over
there just check it out see if there's
something you like or something that a
loved one or
a liked
one would uh also love I mean the stuff
is nuts look at this it's so nice wo it
is it's frankly wo huh it's wo that's
hot yeah so go check it out uh this is
the coolest scarf ever too by the way
that's cool yeah dude that's awesome
that's legit pretty legit oh it's sold
out it's out of stock you can't get that
oh too bad oh man that I feel like this
could be a staple item it's such a great
cool
thing there it is yeah but that and so
much more head on over to Teddy fr.com
check it out thank you to thank you
thank you thank
you did I say gamer Subs already you did
okay
um uh Dan wanted me to mention about the
live show do not come early with peace
and love the seats are assigned oh
there's no need to come stand outside
the theater for hours good point yeah
there was uh at the last show at the ace
which was also a sign seating there was
a line pretty much around the block yeah
from like 11:00 a.m. or something and uh
you just don't need to do that yeah
everybody will get in you have an
assigned seat maybe they're just excited
yeah I mean you you could show up a
little before the doors open may they
want to be at first at the teddy fresh
sample sale uh I suppose there is that
as well but there will be plenty of time
for that um actually uh I think that
they're going to open the doors 30
minutes early because of that um it was
was originally supposed to be 6 but
they're going to open the doors at 5:30
um so come so 5:30 the door's open so
just come at 5:30 um the Dolby is very
equipped to handle large crowds you will
get through the door very quickly so I I
wouldn't worry too much about that and
uh the merch team that's coming is
pretty big I think we have like eight or
nine people coming to work at the table
so um pretty efficient so um so yes I I
think that's good advice you do not need
to come stand in the elements with peace
and love I mean if you want to for some
reason stop and and and the um the Dolby
is kind of like it's hard to explain
it's kind of in a mall and so it's it's
not really like there's not really a
good place to form a long line anyways I
I think security at the mall would
probably come tell you guys you have to
leave anyways so just don't bother like
I've never been there it's that the mall
uh it's at that big so there's a big
kind of shopping complex at Hollywood
Highland and it's attached to it um and
the main entrance to it is sort of in
part of the mall so so
excited I saw Taj to Daniel Taj is a big
deal yeah he's doing a standup show at
the Dolby oh oh yeah and I'm like
well listen
Daniel who you owe your entire format to
me I invented reacting videos
online you know even though he was DED
say about that no toub was toub over
before I guess that show's been around
for a while well of course of course the
predecessor is America's Funniest Home
Videos yeah um sag the goat yeah the
goat
Rip but uh anyway whatever I'm just
being silly no problem with Daniel Tosh
do we like Daniel TSH we do right I I
don't know frankly I've never seen his
show I uh I've been to really enjoy
Tosh.O okay there's some hits and misses
with that show but overall I think it's
a it's way better than uh
Ridiculousness oh you can't even compare
the two it's all of MTV's programming
now look at it's all ridiculous I can't
understand that yeah I I wasn't sure if
you said this and I was a little
confused but uh the chat is saying the
same thing did you call him Daniel Taj
TSH TSH okay well I did say whatever Taj
point0 Daniel Taj Mahal Taj
Mahal what the well-known Indian
comedian I don't know if that's an
Indian
surname the Taj Mahal is actually a MOS
have gamer SS is that right yeah I
believe so he built it didn't he buil it
as like a it's a memorial for his wife
yeah he built it for his wife oh it's on
a mosque but it was a Muslim ruler that
built it right now we're moving the
goalpost okay I well why you worried
about my wife I think a human built it
though I think human beings did build it
I think human beings did build that yeah
a good guess when I go there next month
I'll let you guys know oh that's true
you're going to you're going to see the
tou Mahal when you go yep that's cool
yeah if you're in India or planning to
be in India over the um the break like
cam will be there so keep your eyes open
keep your eyes
peeled we're doing a meet and greet in
indiaia in the most populous country in
the world India is it the most populous
in the world it is now it is they passed
China did they it is number number one
this year congrat congratulations guys
good thing there's plenty of there's
plenty of food to go around plenty of
money and food and resources to go
around absolutely oh yeah India that's
crazy India
population 1.4
Billy damn China what happened bro used
to be the number one people producer
they're uh they're 1.4 wait hold on hold
on according to google 1.48 billion in
India
1.42 fortunately Google is a terrible
search engine that gives you the wrong
answers to everything all the time now
uh I don't know what happened but yeah
here's a un report from a few months ago
that India overtakes China China
congrats look how and look and look how
many people are there look just in this
one picture look the whole country just
shoulder to shoulder
I got to say I'm very jealous of Cam
getting to go on this trip to India that
has been near the top of my list of
places I've wanted to visit for a long
time be going all over so seem fun if I
didn't meet Ethan I probably would have
gone to India you would have F you would
have met you probably would have met
some weird hippie Israeli
dude you probably have like at this you
probably have in alternate universe
hairry armpits and like uh you'd smell
like moth balls or whatever I don't know
Hipp have a smell they have they all
have the same smell it's almost dirty
but not quite and it's it's probably
that organic deodorant or something
right no no no no it's just sweat I used
to work with a guy who was like in the
whole like spiritual world or whatever
the the guy that I had the connection
with brzo with and he um would squirt uh
lemon juice in his armpits and he's
that's gnarly dude that's there's no
shot I didn't have the heart to tell him
but it definitely wasn't working what is
the um wash that hippies use I don't
know if it's that Dr bromer they
all use the same stuff they all use the
toothpaste with no fluoride it's like
bro that's what my that's what my
one-year-old son uses oh Toms is that
what it's called
Toms yeah you you got you need fluoride
that's the whole ass point of the tooth
paste uh what is the wash that hippies
use isn't it bie yeah oh I see people
saying that in the chat I sent in a
Discord Puli pachuli
oil um Tosh.0 started in
2009 P pachuli oil has been used for
thousands of years but gain tremendous
popularity because of it's used by
hippies experts said that the regular
use of petol oil by hippies is because
of the raw earthy and
natural nature of this oil okay maybe
that is I would like to smell some P cuz
I could I could smell is undeniable I a
ton of people in the chat are saying
that so I think I think that's it okay
so I you know they all smell the same
they do well we all think part of it is
the is the deodorant like no deodorant
or organic stuff it's like the smell of
dreadlocks that too there's like you
know when you see it it's there's a
smell you know there's a ducky crying
ducky he's in his need to take a nap
now oh he's so cute he doesn't
sleep enough cuz he's just so excited
yeah and we are too you balance so but
he's supposed to be sleeping like like
most of the day hours 18 hours a day and
the first day he came I don't he didn't
sleep almost at all he's such a good boy
like good he he'll complain a little bit
but then he he's so quick such a good
boy he's so cute a good
yeah we need to force him to sleep
otherwise he doesn't yeah exactly that's
what I've learned cuz the first day was
just like up almost the whole day yeah
he's a biter by the way that's another
thing where he's got the sharpest little
puppy teeth man God my hands are
destroyed and he just wants to play so
like that's his go-to is just bite and
it really hurts so I like I react fast
and he thinks I'm playing so he does it
even more yeah I go Ela don't move and
then ela's pushing him off and then he
comes back harder because he thinks
she's playing yeah he's a brutal little
biter but we'll get there yeah I'm going
to watch some videos on on training it's
it's uh very important for the puppy to
bite you when they're young and for you
to react and like say I uh that's how
they learn for when they're adult so
it's good that they're biting you now
and that you're reacting yeah yeah it's
just I I'll watch videos about it but
when I react he just does it more he
gets more excited you need to find out
the way to yeah like a loud sound or
like there's something like hey that
startles him yeah that's the perfect way
to handle it
um
um I need pachuli oil in my
dreadlocks no hippie hate though I don't
hate them when did I say that I said
they all smell the same just
saying do a poll do all hippie smell the
same oh my God
what are they going to accuse me of
racial stereotyping hippies get out of
here you know what I
mean go ahead do it
Dan this hippie hate dude it is not
hippie hate this PO at its core is hippy
hate it is not like what's wrong with
saying they all smell the same they do
my uh I mean you said that and everybody
in the chat said Julie oil so I guess
you're kind of I am talking about white
people with dreads by the way my my oh
yeah you should definitely specify that
you're talking about hippie I mean when
you're putting when you're when you have
a an image of your head of what I'm
talking about of course they're white
yeah um most hippies tend to be do all
hippies smell the same if it wasn't you
Dan he's just like different dimension
or something um my dead beat piece of
grandfather wears a
pachuli what wait why did you
characterize them like that
wa do you beef with you and your yeah we
don't got to get into it but that smell
is uh well you no well you brought it up
you called him a dead beat yeah he's a
piece of yeah what happened he
abandoned my father oh um and he's but
is he back kind of sort of he tries to
be and but he and he has a smell yeah
it's p truly is your dad forgiven him
no dude interesting why so so how
old was your dad when he left
uh 10 months he took off to New York and
he left my grandmother behind 10 months
then he he tried to get back in my Dad's
life and uh it it was a whole thing is
he local he lives down in the desert so
he's in Cali but not in La
yeah well him yeah yeah so
stinky stinky loser stinky dead beat
stinky stinky loser why would you leave
when your children are having a baby you
know yeah I've tried to talk to him
about it but he's a narcissistic piece
of and just no getting through to
him yeah well you kind of have to be to
pull some crazy like that so
Puli stinky ass it's all the pul
stinky ass yeah Nick Mau
thank you for the gifted than you gifted
thank you gifted wait we're getting all
kinds of generous uh situations here but
let's stay focused if we can please well
there was a 50 that we should probably
shout out 50 GI go ahead from uh L
so thank you for that low bro very
generous of
you all right let's see we've got to
keep the show tight today because we
just got so much to do by the way the uh
hippie poll is 70% of the audience
agrees with you that's what I'm saying
it's not racist if it's true well it's
not racist at all because you're not
talking about a race hippies are not a
race that's what I meant that's what I
meant that's what I
meant
the turn red well that's
making you're not helping there he's not
a hippie though definitely not and not
just a freak a cool Freak no he's M.R
bro M that's his name put some respect
in his my right there when I
turn
red jimnastic now the
dead I love that part favorite
part what's the problem with today's
post ABY you got you have an issue I
have a major issue okay open
this all right what's the problem can
you can you zoom in to me slightly why
are you gonna Elena this man is
literally about to Slit your
throat is this that is that what your
problem is or the problem with all all
the yeah I know all the I saw it in chat
and then all the comments this is the
best take we had love you want to see
the other T well I mean you want you
want to see some pictur you know you're
not the only one in this photo okay well
well you're the head and where are you
looking I don't I'm just not a great
photo of me by any means but you're not
even looking at the camera okay so
you're saying love failed to choose the
best option I mean somebody's looking
good I think it's a great photo of me
Cam's eyes are
closed be honest when you choose a photo
do you just look at how good you look no
that's the last person I look at yeah I
look Ethan Ila then the girls and then
he looks good then ab and then the rest
of the guys AB here's another photo can
take a yeah sure here's another one love
gave us an alternative option
here this one is of course well this is
well this is prior I could tell because
I was putting my arms around Lena for
the photo so this is prior yeah there is
a there is a good photo of you where you
look happy and stuff like but Ela looks
away I'll send it right now okay well
we'll look and then AB you can decide
which one is the best yeah I got to
defend love here let's see there's one
more before we pick aidean I guess I
could haveed look everyone I mean yeah
she's but she's smiling yeah she's I
could have posted this but oh this one
okay so this this one is actually nice
is not looking at the camera but just in
when I was look cuz also it's kind of
stressful too like upload it to your PC
so sometimes I do miss some but I think
in general I look Ethan looking at the
camera is good for the social media post
no I used to do it before I know it's
it's
stressful so what's the well hold on
though AB seems to still be an issue oh
boy um I I love how I look in all of
them so I mean
fastic that second one we look like
we're in a dog campaign the whole thing
in the arms of an
angel you can save this dog life for 5
cents a month by the way you see this
scar here on my nose that thanks to the
facial lady she literally put a
dent in my
nose yeah I don't think that's supposed
to happen yeah but okay whatever
although I don't know in Israel when I
was younger I would go and get those
sometimes and you come out looking like
all scarred it's crazy
bro that cannot be good oh my nose is
massive this is one more this
one this is the only other one so AB
which one would you have
chosen here this is is not with it this
I'm not with it we look crazy you're
not again these are all prior because I
don't have my arms around Lena so that's
how I know it's
before love doesn't know that they are
I'm not saying I'm not saying it was
targeted I'm just saying it it wasn't it
wasn't reviewed very well but all the
other ones you don't like either every I
I love the I
love any other one any other one is okay
any other one is you know I have to say
I think reviewing these though overall
made a good choice this one isn't I mean
I know you look kind of
wild but what's your what's your problem
with the way that you look then looks so
beastful it looks like I'm about to
murder my wife right right look I mean
you can look at the comments oldj you
also have a like blue ethereal
beard you know what I mean ab's like you
know what I mean you know what I
mean and
uh
you'd be surprised how many young girls
there are with Grandpa
issues you You' be surprised how many
girls got father issues and granddaddy
issues shock and how many of them girls
got granddaddy issues that's right this
one's from New Hampshire that's you
AB I I look crazier than OJ ever looked
I don't know about that brother you've
seen that one with the banana where he
pretends to stab the reporter Okay
imagine imagine he looked like that when
he did it I mean Ian didn't complain and
he's not having a great photo moment I
looks great I thought I looked fine what
yeah why are you saying that what the
hell does that me he looks
great I was going to say that if you
look at the I mean his eye is a little
weird looking here
stop you look ug like that it's just a
weird busted dude you look like
your F your face doesn't look like
I'm just saying it's not a great
photo of not insulting like how you
physically look in real life there's I
mean I'm going back to this I mean here
I am Ian do you think this is a great
photo of me you know it happens me this
is actual I was going to say that if you
count the people in the photo the
majority of of them have a good photo
here so I think he made the good call
and for the record under the time
constraint he has to make a quick
decision let's we can count him Ethan's
not looking Ian's High cam isn't
looking's okay so let me defend
myself of the pictures cam will just
close his eyes like he'll in the past
has just closed his eyes on I don't
think I don't think that's
listen I'm not you Clos your eyes on
purpose no there's definitely been been
pictures where I have like seven
pictures and all the pictures you have
your eyes
Clos receipts right now cuz I don't
believe that's true at all I I could try
to dig keep my eyes open no I'm not
saying I I I know it has happened in the
past but listen I've been there I'm not
blaming you I know it's stressful um but
I'm just saying you ruined my whole
winter
break I'm kidding you may not be kidding
about it I know you you take things
really you do take them quite doesn't
sound like a joke just just like the
flock of face was a real disaster for
this is like this is this is close to it
this getting there oh my God no it's not
it's not
photo after you make it a big deal it's
going to be yeah you are no complaining
about this when this is a meme for the
next year nobody thought about it
exactly but now you are OJ Simpson I
think that
overall looking back at Love's photos
not just today they're all really good
for everybody for the majority and in
love's to defend love his camera does
sort of morph us a lot I feel like so
the problem is your his your phone love
we need to upgrade I think the cam the
photos look great sharp well you know
what next year we have all year to work
and
perfect thank you AB for the input and
we apologize for yeah I I something
think about over break
just we'll all something tells me you'll
be thinking about it more than us but I
will practice your poses AB the mirror
true do you do that a no no but I maybe
I
should I do I'll be honest you do yeah I
want to know which smile looks the best
I know we look at can we look back at
this one what you still looking
backwards on the what you got for me
you're going I got it yeah I don't have
Discord on my
phone uh here we go time let's
see so right this one looks fine what's
wrong with this one does it this is
before so well zoom in more oh well okay
I mean I don't care about how I look
though that's me everybody that's what I
that's my face you know what I
mean like at a certain point you just
got to be like that's me who wants to
look at this fat face oh my God
Zach so that's with my normal personal
phone and I have another phone with a
really good camera that I use pretty
much only for taking pictures and ab you
look good you looking like us
paralal over there like it
I was trying to remember why was I
dressed up that day that was the night
we were going to uh uh markess oh that's
why nice nice yeah you look good thank
you you look like potentially like a
real on a card kind of
situation yeah on a but like on a bus
stop bench mhm I don't know I see gives
a call center to me call center yeah who
the is that nice for a call center
a polo shirt the
manager yeah maybe a manager of a call
center the iish
manager Tim hucker Throwing Shade at us
uh whatever oh this is upsetting
I I'll pull it up then I guess if you
we're doing beef here and he said
explicitly I'm doing this to cause beef
so you know what Tim I'll take
the beef and shame on you by the way um
piece of for
even attempting to come after
us oh yeah Tim hucker you guys remember
what was that show that he was really
popular for I forget it's been so
long uh well I am a huge on Cinema head
but I am a I'm a fan of his co-host 50
other people watch that yeah I'm a and
I'm more of a Greg Head anyway GRE too
yeah uh Tim is a on that
show uh he's really exposed himself in
that show it's a psychopath so yeah so
let's hear what he has to say here Tim
whoever that is hidecker
and I have no audio by the way oh well
maybe they are the king of drops
then yep is that you Zach everything's
up what the hell my is it muted on
computer got muted again it's so weird
because it was before the show should
this should the sound bar be full Dan oh
it should be full all right let me do
that okay oh oh I hear that noise here
we go so stop looking at me look
anywhere else buddy all
good yeah just anywhere else man not a
great
place you know who that is a special
guest ah probably some secret guest that
nobody knows about um no I noticed this
Doug I saw the majority report they're
like totally uh going down to drop drop
Heaven Drop Zone mhm whatever you want
to say majority majority P hitting drops
like nobody and E I mean what's his name
Ethan Klein at h3h3 not to start beef
but their their drops are more yeah it's
it's like I know we're not saying we
invented the drop I mean that's this is
a radio you know it's been happening
forever but it does seem like we're
having an influence on culture in a way
you know
Nick and I we do drops we do custom
drops so your drops are plean guys
listen I've seen what your drops are
it's like oh like like you're doing
like sound effects of a cartoon
like what the are you doing
Three Stooges we're doing an actual show
here right Zach this is this is you Tim
doing a
drop it's offensive uh to think I no and
I very publicly and Fred Norris is the
goat you know well according to Tim he
invented drops idiot
just don't even don't even go
there Tim I I love I love your
don't even you know what I uh
picked up on in that clip is he pointed
out that they have Vick and Doug on
their show doing drops it takes two
people do Zach's job yeah for
thisp
what are we watching here Looney Tunes
give me a break well some of those
chiropr do sound like Looney Tunes to be
fair literally Amateur hour office hours
more like Amateur hour
oh give me a let's go give me a
break give me a break yeah what was that
show you did again I I don't remember
it's been like two to three decades
something in Eric it was like something
in something in Eric right guy Eric
warheim I know he's really oh yeah the
goat like he he needs to get off his
high horse yeah sit down if you want to
lesson Tim I more glad you can come here
and I can show how it's done properly
well we'll have to charge him for that I
don't want to give that away for free
interesting that'll be a paid gig right
all right hang them you know with our
chaos pads you know if
people
know all right well I think I I I don't
want to start any beefs but maybe his
show right now what are we watching they
they do it's it says it on office hours
live pre-show they do a little Instagram
live before they go live on the on
YouTube wow yeah wow yeah not that I'm
not that I'm a fan or anything no who
would
be but anyway uh Tim hopefully Tim
please don't respond until we're back
from break because we'll be gone for
three weeks and we'll miss it we're
gonna but I'll you know what I'll I'll
I'll I watch I see everything okay
so zip it this is you this needs to be
you you should be careful because Tim
heaker actually is a he's a murderer
he's actually he's actually been on
trial for you think I'm scared killing
like 20 people yeah not scared about
that come at me Tim yep come
find me
um Rich Lux uh is has accepted his
speech he he he's he's the winner of The
Sound by
tournament big tip he really is so
iconic he really is I didn't expect it I
don't know why I didn't I never saw it
coming but he really cleaned up uh here
here he is accepting his
award the well folks I won the A3 A3
podcast award I'm I'm shock I don't have
any words thank you to the Klein family
we already know Dan's the queen Dan can
do no wrong thank you guys so much to
the ace R podcast the community the
supporters the haters thank you guys I
appreciate it I'm I'm related my social
media blew up yesterday with so many
letting letting me know that I won so
thank you guys and um I'm excited I
never win anything there you go so I
actually won something so I'm proud of
it all right bye guys well folks I won
the a podast award congratulations Rich
it's a it's a it's such a big award
actually it's an honor yeah especially
in his case it is all love Yeah like
when you look at the 5% one she may not
she may not necessarily be stok that she
won sure but Rich Lu can enjoy this how
you look at it you know M how would you
how do you look at it where she's happy
about it just kind of like going with it
and um accepting it for what it is and
just how iconic it
honestly Ed but she could have embraced
it that is not what happened he takes
that
5% he takes that 5% have there been any
any of the other winners that like would
have been happy about winning in like in
the case of rich like have they all yeah
tipster he tweeted about it no I mean
I'm sorry I meant uh like previous
year's winners Sor was Howie thrilled oh
Howie would have been like happy about
that sure he about it he turned around
on the whole PR yeah but I would but the
other one is like we don't have a
communication with um sh out to shout
out to if Dave Gua knew would have been
honored but anyway tipster wrote a very
you know very classy he said cheers my
dude
rep love you no homo we love them both
don't we
folks good
sportsmanship here is D okay you guys
remember this guy he made this animation
dark Nathaniel Clansman he it's like um
he did it with fabric or something the
first time the stop motion it's a stop
motion but yeah he did it with like
fabrics and stuff and it was really
really really good uh you keep saying he
I I don't oh it's a i Mumsy I don't know
Mumsy Undead so they they also they were
trying to promote which I want to
promote apparently Sound by bees from
space Mumsy Undead on YouTube you guys
should check it out in fact Let me watch
it on YouTube yeah instead of
redit so you guys can see Undead mummy
it's called and I got to be honest this
one is not what I expected and
uh it hit me pretty it hit me it hit me
really hard actually but I'll play for
you guys and I'll try not
to I'll try to be cool about
[Music]
it oh his power always
M God won't put me here on this hell on
[Music]
[Applause]
Earth I tell you he didn't wake
up he just kept on
[Music]
[Applause]
sleeping I just stand behind him and
watch and Man's last moment here on this
Earth he didn't even say you
coming
[Music]
h
[Applause]
[Music]
h
why did you do that that was so good
though so
beautiful I'm still
unemployed well that is a shame because
you are so talented yeah that's a crime
got me all Misty eyed man honestly so
talented though yeah it's the craft that
goes making that yeah the first one was
just a silly comedy and so I watched it
with that
expectation oh dude I was a
mess yeah a lovely tribute though yeah
well done well
done yeah anyway shout out Undead Mommy
I want to give him a big shout out that
was
awesome and I guess the uh beast from
space did the all the sound design on it
that's what he said in this in the
Reddit thread yeah well that's uh very
cool
yeah that guy gets around man I love
it um anyway
yeah excuse
me thank you up next we've got
um Boogie which who has been a somewhat
of a fixture on the show
lately uh he we've talked about he made
a new podcast with
keemstar yeah called
lolcow and um
the first episode and you guys remember
keemstar was saying that he wanted him
to to unal Alive himself that he hated
it it was one of the most unhinged
psychotic rants potentially
ever on Rich's stream oh it wasn't even
on the show right it was that that was
like in
DM or something yeah but but anyway
their second episode is out and we're
all big fans since um your mom's house
your mom's basement is uh no more when
we missed that show we really R to the
goat man we do still have L cow live and
don't worry if you you don't you don't
need to watch that show we'll we'll
bring you all the best highlights here
for comment and criticism of course um
did you actually sit down and watch it
no of course not okay I did did you
really I did yeah I don't know what
keem's doing he's sort of trying to be
like a motivational speaker now or
something it's weird I don't know but
what about that that message he sent
Boogie wasn't inspirational right he's
like and and in this podcast he's super
loud and the other two are so quiet it
was driving me insane last night when I
was trying to like I was trying to ride
the uh the volume because it was just
wild yeah so um boogy has been eating
dog food for likes oh my God and that's
actually something he's literally doing
so let's enjoy that
up this is I don't give a no more boogie
here we go oh god oh no oh no all right
so we'll start with what is this shave
little well I got to go back he explains
why he's doing it we got 403 right now
403 likes guys everyone like the
stream yeah
everyone we
go you're right K is I don't give a no
more boogie here we go oh god oh no oh
no all right so we'll start this is such
a bizarre show sh little like a little
dog B
here you are
fat I don't care you are God is terrible
why do my dogs eat this good analysis
there you ate a tiny Pebble of dog food
you're
fat what's the relation dude he's not
eating it cuz he's hungry this is so
cursed man yeah this this show is cursed
as God cuz Boogie was like we only
have 60 likes could you guys like the
video and keem's like don't tell him to
like without providing any entertainment
you got to do something if you want them
to like it so he starts suggesting some
random
stuffstar he wants to not be the lcow so
bad he is the LOL cow though that's
what's interesting he is one of them and
he's right in the middle snap dab right
in the middle there all right but anyway
here let's enjoy Boogie eating more dog
food for
likes okay well that one's gross this
one's red of redemption
is literally not even paying attention
and I'll be right back find that
SoundCloud gross seems Disturbed
that's so gross okay sound cloud this
one looks good this one's got like a
marbled beef feeling to it here there we
go up you know Boogie like dog
food is regulated so that if the
American economy would ever fail that
dog food has to be edible by hum that is
for sure not true that that there's no
way that's true I've never heard of that
what kind of Psy C it yeah you know uh
back in the Reagan Era he said listen if
there's if there is a nuclear war we
must be prepared therefore all dog food
has to be fit for human consumption
which is funny because most dog food has
literally especally written on it not
for human
consumption uh that's nuts can you fact
check that uh I'm saying a product
formulated for pet is unlikely to be
nutritionally adequate for humans and
vice versa because pets become like
family members in many homes it should
be underscored that not everything that
a human can eat is safe for a pet well
yeah obviously um yeah so seeming like
no definitely not true dude that's so
funny that's the weirdest take ever the
way it's worded though it sounds like
it's not necessarily that it's dangerous
to eat it but that you couldn't survive
off of it would be dangerous to eat
probably not kibble but like that wet
I don't know about all that
anyway oh my God this one like bacon huh
look at this one right here there a
little red white marble thing oh come
here for a second ke s didn't even get
up he he he he got up he didn't even
stick around for like the Highlight yeah
he's like I need water I don't know he
was also like it seems like fake
laughing just this whole thing is very
bizarre very weird Vibes yeah here we go
yeah ke is still gone and he's still
eating dog food he's still
going oh no we have a thousand thousand
buddy I'm taking mine back you spit it
out at one point earlier on in the
podcast uh Boogie's girlfriend isers
it's under my go ahead sorry Boogie's
girlfriend's leaving the house and
keem's like oh where is she going to
someone her age and it's like irony
who are you what what excuse me
sir you can't be making those types of
jokes there bucko wonder what this
tastes like yeah anyway the what is dog
food uh taste like podcast great all
happening beat my ex-wife and I'm also a
pedophile right I can see why you're
doing that show the prospects are not
great so that's but that's what's going
on Boogie if you guys were curious let
me change your mind I was but I I regret
it now yeah
well but you're right I can button it I
respect your
decision uh Tim P says he will not be
playing GTA 6 why
oh you well you have you heard about GTA
6 it's has a woman
protagonist uhhuh but isn't there women
before also on the game like as a main
character I don't I no I think this is
the first time that um but it's uh not
there's actually two main protagonists
and then and there a couple and you can
play both at least okay that's
speculated uh what the game's going to
be like so that but Ethan it's even
worse than playing a woman it's actually
way worse than that what cuz it's a
Latino woman right oh God forbid it's
woke wow yep and what's supposed to be
Miami I mean right there's no Latino
Latin no Miami for sure so let's see um
Tim pool will not be playing GTA 6
because women aren't physically capable
of hurting men and therefore the game is
unrealistic oh my god of course ignoring
the fact that um we uh
Weaponry is of course
gender uh you any gender can use a gun
right that is very true yeah very true
as of now at least the technology to
check genders hasn't caught up yet but
here go ahead Tim you're the man play uh
uh GTA okay you are running around
punching and beating people and shooting
people and stealing cars yeah you know
personally I don't want to play a female
character uh that's not I I don't know
if it really matters but bro are you
sure you sound like such a baby are you
sure you want to put this online I don't
want to play a fale g like bro you are a
grown ass man you put this online
willingly that's crazy to me has he ever
watched The Fast and Furious it's like
one of the biggest franchise worldwide
he refuses not real yeah it's unrealist
that's the most unrealistic thing about
the Fast and the Furious music you know
the
Rodriguez yeah you remember that scene
when the car did like 100 yard jump over
Canyon on a rope swing yeah well the
woman driving that super unrealistic
yeah a woman couldn't do that if Vin
Diesel was driving that car maybe I
would buy it big problem big problem I
just can't suspend my disbelief that
far it's kind of weird in my mind and
look you know you can tell me that I'm
wrong or something I don't know I just
how I feel like this lady is going to
run up to a random guy in the street and
punch him and he's going to go down no
come on what it is a cartoon oh my God I
mean you you also can drive on a random
street and find a tank and start driving
it yes exactly yeah that's not going to
happen so I'm not J you can jump out of
an airplane and hit the cement and get
up hold on though how many women could
go up to Tim and beat his ass tons of
them I'll do it I suggest like a like a
badass gangster girl who's like down
who's used to getting Scrappy and stuff
she could definitely floor your ass dude
what are you talking about literally
what let's get you in the ring with like
uh one of these uh like an MMA F they'll
kill you one of those for sure
will kill him yeah no no chance even the
best woman fighter in the world has no
chance against me yeah what a
loser you literally uploaded this that's
so interesting to me that you actually
did
that yo if you're ever Aver woman ran to
your average guy and swung a fist at him
it's not going to hurt him I mean you're
not even going to hurt him ladies you're
not he won't even feel it since when
does the game need to be realistic
anyway I don't understand this the both
he's wrong on both ends I
know wow
man he is single right and childless uh
I do not know his relationship status uh
you know the problem is though it's
definitely not me yeah so that that clip
was from about two years ago or so now
so U maybe he's Found Love since then
he's complained that he doesn't have
kids so I'm assuming he still is
childless which is not an L for
everybody but for him it is a fat
L well problems everybody else have you
considered adoption I mean you know
there's there are other
means you don't need to find someone to
reproduce with it's definitely not me
you know adopt sure you know you can and
please don't encourage to adop child get
please don't do that yeah I'm fine with
him not having kids yeah no this is this
is a good setup we have yeah I think it
works out for every no amount of
children but here's the deal his kids
would be like straight up re Rebel
Rebellion against him they would be like
the fattest sjw's ever yeah
absolutely a little bit but it's not
think Elon musk's she's not by the way
but think about Elon Musk with his
transgender daughter I don't know
anything about her for the record but
there's like he disowned her so that's
what Tim is well I think it was the
other way around she disowned him she
disowned him yeah she emancipated
herself which certainly makes sense when
you consider his opinions about his own
daughter dude have a heart it's
pretty wild GNA like put him down and
then so my point was like okay so you
play as this character you run up and
punch a random guy and then he just
clocks you in the face one time you go
down wasted you lose all your HP
instantly and then you wake up outside
the
hospital Tim you are a giant you are a
giant you could not knock someone
out I know that for sure so like who
which men are we talking about that's
doing this and it's like what this is
like so not a new thing like yeah car
his temp there's so many video games
characters almost in all games here's
have a problem with Street Fighter cuz
of Chun Lee like who's winning this
fight if anything it's also already so
designed for men like the female
characters are always so hot and it's
like right exactly what are you even
arguing about they designed it for you
to enjoy it it's just who who you
putting your Buy on
guys um my girl yeah you sure well
that's the thing in the clip he says the
average woman but it's like first of all
it's a video game so that's who cares
and second of all it this character is
an average woman she's like a hardened
criminal like most GTA protagonists you
know what I mean and also like you point
out Ethan there are guns in the game
mostly guns I mean mostly what you do
most of the disputes are are resolved
with weapons not not fistic cuffs yeah
so just so anyway shout out Tim P who
literally decided to upload that take to
the internet that's
incredible so we love them cated we we
love them them on the right are really
ahead of the game and love them look how
he's sleeping we get a shot Puppy Cam oh
my God oh my God what are
you you are so
funny that is incredible so funny
D dcko the Bucko D the
Bucko
wow that's
awesome what you
ducko chill Jordan you even hate my
dog um new dancing guy video it's
exciting oh we got to do ad I was about
to interrupt to say It's Time guys we
love gamer Subs here on the H3 podcast
we live for gamer Subs in fact we love
it so much we made our own
flavor Sigma brain which is a special
blend formulated with great care and
effort here in the office by all of us a
sweet Cy lemon lime flavor with a tinge
it's spicy spicy Margarita yeah however
if you don't like spicy food I promise
this will not it's a it's more of a Ence
it's a hint it's a tickle I promise if
you are adverse to spicy you will like
this it is not going to mess up your
experience but we love it and I love
gamer Subs why first of all it's a
sugar-free brage that energizes me it's
full of caffeine it's full of vitamins
minerals electrolytes it gets me buzzing
mhm I'd be like I need
electrolytes I'm thirsty I need
water I need to pick me
up one tip for every for every cause
they've got tons of great flavors though
besides uh Sigma brain If you hooked on
sugary
drinks switch to this immediately mhm I
promise that will change your
life no reason really to consume sugar
in my opinion especially in a beverage
mhm I'm so out on sugary beverages like
you kick back like a almost 200 calories
in a Coca-Cola yo I'm seeing a lot of
positive feedback on Sigma brain in the
chat that's nice to see and I'm glad
because I really genuinely do it it's a
fantastic flavor I agree think we did
good we did good but it it honestly if
you're looking for just a nice flavored
drink to sip at home they have
uncaffeinated they have caffeinated it
really is such a great beverage I mean
love you you this is you don't even
drink water right no I have this weird
thing in my brain where I don't really
like
water and we like water products and
since I've been drinking and S drinks in
for a long time I've really fine tune
how to drink these I buy bottled water
and then I put it in the bottled water
Direct
and do you do you refrigerate it or yeah
I got a bunch of water in the fridge
take one out boom one scoop one and a
half maybe Shake That Thing Up and boom
I have a drink to to just bring out the
door you know I thought that was wild
but I'll be honest um Dr ID says he does
the same damn thing and he's a doctor he
goes I don't ever drink water like what
apparently you can do I didn't know you
could do that so I mean I don't know how
long you can do that but I guess why not
it's it's 99% water yeah
99.5% water just a little it's just a
little flavor all different flavors and
you can you can do a half scoop if you
want less flavor too that's the cool
thing you can like fine tune where sweet
spot is you find that you're drinking
more liquid cuz it's it tastes 100%
because I that's probably good yes and
also I'm sometimes I'm tired of uh
sparkling drinks cuz it's you can't
really it's annoying when you're thirsty
it's nice to have something still it's
not good for my heart or my heart
condition my heartburn yeah right the
carbonation is really bad for gird yeah
me
too um so
listen please consider supporting them
try them out uh I guarantee you're going
to love it right now you can get a free
wfu cup when you buy select G tubs go to
Gamers subs. g.com gamer oh wait hold on
Gamers subs. gg.com okay we got two
dots wait that's what they said gamer
subs.
g.com doeses that make
sense
just yeah yeah no that doesn't lead
anywhere so that is backrack don't add
the.com it's just Gamers subs. and by
the way you're welcome that was on me
don't be asking for make good you sent
me this not that they would they
come we love them and if you uh and if
you do the SL H3 at the end it'll take
you straight to the uh Sigma brain so
one more time gamersupps.gg is what
where you want to be yeah
yeah uh also go to Gamers subs. G and
use the code H3 to get 10% off your
order hey yeah so anyway thank you to
for being such a great supporter of the
show uh to gamer
subs and consider getting yourself a tub
baby thank you guys o this is a new
track H that debuting this one today oh
yeah oh yeah
uh I I think I might have okay yeah it's
a Vibe though it is a vibe
[Music]
it's kind of giving like Bruno Mars
maybe like hold
on what's that song he did about it's a
100 Gold Fever 24 Karat yeah 24 Gold
Fever 100 gold I have this labeled as
funky MJ vot so yeah yeah yeah yeah I
like Bruno Mars he's good at pop
music I love Mar he's got he he gives
like a little Michael Jackson like in
terms of the talent and of his music he
is so consistently incredible yeah he's
he's crazy
talented he yeah he idolizes MJ and
Elvis if I'm not mistaken that's an
interesting combo I definitely see the
MJ influence like Big Time
Elvis okay I just got somebody just left
this chat message that is fascinating to
me I've never heard of this before and I
just Googled it and I do see articles
about it that the LA tap water has a
harmless algae that bloom booms in the
summer and makes the water smell and
taste like dirt not everyone can taste
it but I could it was a factor in me
moving away from LA and I was like that
can't be real I just Googled it why
California's tap water tastes bad in the
summer here it is what I gu complaints
of earthy or musty taste or smell I mean
I've lived here my whole life I I
apparently I probably just used to it or
something cuz I've never heard about
this before I mean I generally don't
drink tap water sometimes I will in like
the middle of the night if I just go to
the sink or something uhhuh and it I
mean it always tastes like in La
it's it's never tasted good in SoCal
ever like compared like living up north
the water tastes great yeah you come to
La New York it's like New York and La
has got to have or New York was good
yeah the water was perfect LA's got to
have the nastiest tasting tap water in
the world huh in the country well you
might actually be right because
apparently there's there's behind that
that's why they say New York Bagels are
way better is because of such bull I
believe did I mean water is a big
ingredient in it if the LA water is
they you know the Israelis say
the same thing about hummus they go it
was one guy it's not the Israel no this
is what they do when they don't want to
explain their recipe they go it's the
water give me it's not the water it's
not the water I think it's a big factor
no it's okay it's can't be it's
impossible listen Ethan I you made a cup
of coffee and that's all water with LA
tap water versus New York tap water you
would not taste the difference and
that's all
water let's well let's get a cup from
the east coast and do listen my whole my
whole water world has been turned upside
down this year by Martin um and now I I
would have agreed with you in the past
Ethan fully it was just like ah this is
just people being silly
but I think there might be something to
it it's you can't I I know what you're
saying but in the mix of a of a bagel
dough with all the other stuff in there
else going on there there's no way
because in New York you're you're
talking texture you're talking
fluffiness they tend to be fresher I
think and so you're you're the water is
not affecting the fluffiness huh you
know what I mean also real quick uh uh
little PSA because you mentioned Martin
reminded me I need to change my w water
filter so if you have the uh you have
the shower filter you should have oh so
I've replaced it once since he came but
it probably is getting close to be a
second time I think it's three to six
months is the I never got to use it
because my shower head was
incompatible you you I did though but
honestly I didn't notice any difference
did you guys I did you did I thought it
made my hair a lot more lustrous yeah it
might be because my hair was so damaged
from coloring and stuff that it was like
not noticeable true it's hard to absorb
anything when you're all burned out um
we can do an experiment now Zach we can
two cups of coffee one with water and
one with tap
water a big difference our tap water is
filtered in this building isn't it no
it's not get it from the scene wait but
isn't this New York versus LA thing but
I'm saying the difference between a
bottled water and La tap water is not is
going to be similar difference between
New York and La if you could tell the
difference between those two you could
tell the difference between bottled
water and the sparklets is bottled from
California water then it wouldn't be
that right no from the tap water I have
a thing not sparkly that's purified
Sodis in La tastes different than in
Sweden and I'm 99% sure it's the tap
water or it's the water they use give I
don't know where the water is bottled
though that that could be they have
different formulas though in Europe
because there's different regulations
and stuff oh are you talking about like
regular any soda here I feel the tap
water underneath the soda you talking
about sugar or diet diet both Coke
because I know in most places the cola
uses cane sugar and America uses corn
syrup which could definitely changed the
flavor of it yeah not every drink I
drink out here I feel the water below
better or worse worse
mhm that's a shame uh I got to say there
are some Bakers coming for you for your
water doesn't matter I know they I know
they think it matters but it doesn't
well this is a 27mon member so you have
to respect your
I bake sourdough and water you use
absolutely affects the texture flavor
and overall consistency of the bread SL
Bagels I
just you're telling me a New York Bagel
then doest Z doesn't taste different
than a I'm not on them a
Western Bagel you can make a bagel
depends who's making it you if you the
same people come to LA and make the
bagel it's going to taste the same n
you're you're so off bro do the test
then do the coffee test we're going to
need an official bagel maker to chime in
I feel like right but they're they're
the ones propagating this
thisas why would they what's their
because they they don't want to give
away their secrets the same with the
hummus guys it's so proprietary these
recipes especially hummus like people
live and die by hummus recipes and and
I'm telling you they go oh it's the
waters they didn't have to entertain you
asking have you ever seen those guys on
Tik Tok The Bagel dudes um I've never
seen a bagel like that before in LA the
the appearance the it it's it's just
amazing wait so before we go on that
have you actually had a New York Bagel
or you just going off Tik Tok when I was
younger I went to New York when what you
you had a New York Bagel in
decades but Sam Bagel in uh in La is
just as good as a New York Bagel you
think so oh yeah I had a New York I I
had some really bad ones in New York me
too we had a ton of Bagels in New York
the bagels in La I might say on average
have been better so many would be just
be dry and like wow are coming for y'all
right now they're coming dude new the
whole I don't know I don't know if it's
where we lived we lived in Manhattan and
I feel like that's where maybe if you're
like in another no more hip place I feel
like in Manhattan there's a lot of
touristy
spots I don't know you should have been
able to get a good bagel oh oh my God
it's Manhattan you get if there's
something good you can get it there yeah
I guess you guys just don't like the New
York Bagels there were some good ones oh
there were and we well yeah but like
there's good bagels everywhere like we
even looked up like okay you hear about
the New York Bagels like there's some
conspiracy and New Yorkers do this
because it sucks there so they have to
build up these this mythology that
everything there is great but it's
totally normal and so we look up online
where's the best bagel place in New York
we go there and it is average a
the New Yorkers are saying Long Island
is the place for
B I saw we were not at Long Island
that's like being like yeah California
makes La has the best bagel but you have
to drive to like Valley yes yeah
San Diego to get it which place in New
York was it Essa bagel I don't remember
place what do you care though Zach you
haven't been there in two decades it's a
big thing it's it's a Jewish deli thing
I went to one of the big ones okay yeah
cats is I'm seeing a lot of all these
New Yorkers are saying Long Island is
the place for the
bagland that's where the bagel boss is I
mean oh sorry I didn't travel to Long
Island for that explains it and that was
what I was thinking I think Manhattan
doesn't have the best stuff that's ridic
when it comes to food that's ridiculous
there's so much like touristy crap
there yeah but it's a lot of it isn't
you got to go to Long Island you got to
go to Long Island dud nobody wants to go
to long is to Joey salad nobody wants to
go there for any reason dude except to
visit their salads will hook you up with
you're visiting family that's fine any
other reason you turn around that's
where I would go to visit fam exactly
yeah that's a great reason to go there
beautiful place to go only reason I I
haven't been back since why would you I
wouldn't yeah you're right do you guys
know that the sigma brain flavor is out
of stock oh my God wa wait it wasn't a
minute ago did the foa Troopers just
clear them out oh I don't know that's
super cool that uh
wait so if I go here wait why is the
rating down to like almost four stars
wait I was able to uh no it's not pull
that up dude this is somebody
gating four and a half dude haters are
down voting
this it's four and a half dude it's
almost a perfect score what do you want
okay it's it's half it's four and a half
I thought it was that's a 10 it should
be a five though yeah you're right right
I mean it averages so all it takes is a
couple four stars to bring it down a
notch right orle
[Music]
350 um and and and on that I said the
wrong thing and I had to had to take it
back and on that note I wouldn't say
what you said prior okay yeah that's
good but uh yeah no I think it's all
good I'm looking through the reviews
right now let's see uh I'll give you an
example of a not five star review not
the call I won't mention names or
anything but say their name and address
please no I'm not going to do that uh
well I'm mostly here I keep going
look I'm not seeing Oh here here's a
four star flavor is pretty good with a
little little tickle going down that's a
five star review I said four decent
flavor with a little bit of a kick at
the end is another fourar let's say
their finger slipped well read one of
the five stars before you know let's
let's give some voice to the people that
like it well the vast majority it's I'm
having un whoa this person wrote an
essay dude five star an unexpected
favorite I recently tried Sigma brain
energy powder and the spicy lime flavor
and to be honest I didn't have high
expectations I assumed it might be
similar to the other lime fused products
I've tried and would and wouldn't
surpass what I had already do in adding
a little bit of lime juice to the
guacamole gamer fart 9000 oh lime lover
however on the recommendation of a
friend I decided to give it a shot and
I'm so glad I did the spicy lime flavor
of Sigma brain took me by surprise in
the best way possible dude it's a solid
blend that balances The Zing of the lime
with the kick of the dude this
guy's a a fishy he's
a g a this doesn't even sound like this
just sounds like a a gamer sub fan
that's trying different flavors that
this doesn't sound like an hdan W all
different FL so that's that's cool too
was it used with LA top water or New
York top water makes a big difference
they actually go on for like three more
paragraphs but uh we can move on but
I'll say all right here I found a onear
review found one you ready go ahead
spicy lime not a fan of this I prefer
sweet but if you're into lime and spicy
this is the one then why that's not even
that bad it's not well they're just
saying for them it was one star but then
why give it a one star for everybody
when you're like some people would like
don't leave a review people have
different philosophies about the rating
system you can't hold that against them
but that's not even a hater they're
saying you might like it I I not for me
I hold it against them I hope I never
meet
them um I'll say this though when we
said that we spent a lot of time
formulating and perfecting flavor I
meant that we did lots of rounds of that
yeah I think we went back and forth
four or five times of sending of them
sending twe version or is it not the cup
yeah what happened I I know there it's
happening cuz we made a really cool cup
I know what's uh you know I asked I
asked to follow up about that a while
ago and they said they'd let me know and
get back to me and I I think it just
kind of I think it just fell off the
radar I thought it was cool we paid an
artist like a fair bit of money to
create it yeah yeah and it came out
great did we ever show it on the show
no change should we or should we wait
maybe we should wait cuz I don't know
I'm going to send another email and
follow up with them and see selling it
on red bubble by the end that's a good
point yeah yeah we should probably
wait I'll I'll shoot him an email right
now
though thank you where are we we were
talking about
[Music]
uh new dance dancing guy um you know
where we are is at the point in the show
where if we want to get to the
PowerPoint we should probably do it oh
yes we're getting there however okay
this is important it's my boy more
angles have been coming out about
and even a tutorial another angle I need
to know where is this happening who is
he and like what are they doing cuz I've
never seen this like and he's always
with the same like this is his best
friend I can tell CU they're always next
to each other doing it and they're doing
some kind of group
dancing thing I don't know I wonder if
it's in America or if it's somewhere
else but it's giving somewhere else
Vibes but the jords yeah the jords are
giving somewhere else but but at the
same time Buffalo New York they're both
wearing wait what what you know that no
they're wearing George Buffalo New York
oh just keing
star that's good anyway here it
is that's my thought here it goes whoa
dude what the dude hell no look at
the other people next to him no close
this guy on his right is in every video
and this guy is like he is trying his
best yeah he's trying for sure but he's
so not on the level where he needs to be
do you think they're like Father and Son
nah I don't think so his son would be
better at it they're home they're just
friends I think the the main dude his
body just works with it so well I did he
invent this dance I think he must have
I've never seen that before anywhere
else how is it it's like play it
play it watch it and do it here you
click the okay
ready wait
I've been trying it's
hard so I love how they do this too like
yeah he does that so it's just one step
so one foot one foot planted just one
step it's one foot planted and back and
forth and a little and a little rocking
shimmy in there yep yep that's real
close does does anyone else in here have
the ability to do this AB ab's a pretty
good dancer can you do this AB love
not to like put you on the spot I just
wonder if you can nail it like this when
I come back from break maybe but I don't
know you got rehearse it a little bit
put in the
workin well I was trying to do it too I
look so silly you practice it it's
it's I I
can't it's you know it's an advanced
move ah love that guy can we maybe we
could get him a call in I mean we let's
find out who he is okay I would be done
I love him let's fly him
comeback show let's hire first show back
the dancing Tik Tok guy every every 10
minutes he'll just come in and do the
dance he's on payroll although with the
H3 curse do we want to ruin this guy's
life is going to come out that he's like
a serial killer we got to take the
chances yeah we have to take the chance
I don't think anything can touch him he
seems like such a good guy really yeah
can you guys find the tutorial that I've
also seen that one yeah well what is the
name of the dance it it's got a at this
point it has to have that move somebody
said that he released a tutorial yeah oh
he made it yeah his tutorial it's not
good but it's great it looked almost
misleading like intentionally I don't
know it's weird yeah I found it's not
it's a horrible tutorial but I love the
video and this is this is his version of
being like Oh yeah it's in the water
he's like just do what I do but he's not
giving you good advice Mor Morin morinho
is that how you say that Morino
dance
is that him that's him is he American I
think he might be it's so hard to tell I
don't think so but like what's going on
back here this is giving like somewhere
else this room I was going to guess like
southern Europe for some reason it was
giving southern Europe that's a Vibe I
can see that this outfit is not American
to me gree true maybe you're right
European his name is
Jose his name's Jose yes well it could
be in Spain yeah yeah yes yeah yeah
could be Spain I Cyprus maybe yeah
Cyprus looking for his uh account here
Jose though that I mean that's got to be
a Spanish name if he's in Europe what
else what option is there Portugal maybe
Portuguese just based off this Instagram
post saying anyway here's the tutorial
everybody take
notes we got water and
bagels so watch she goes do you do like
this no and by the way he looks sick
doing that that was awesome I was like
is that a new move he looks really good
but no he was telling you this is you
let's
see somebody said his last name is
Brazilian oh and he's wearing Brazilian
soccer jersey Brazil there you go so we
were on to it with the Portuguese It's
Brazil
Brazil maybe he's a Jimmy Lee fan true
Brazil we love Brazil yes come to
Brazil watch this he goes now this is
how it's done this is how it's done
three two one engage
whoa why does he move like he's so good
at it that's crazy and by the way I've
seen tons of people trying to replicate
it who are professional dancers who are
really good at dancing and nobody has
come has come close to the fluidness the
smoothness there's something in the
build of his body that allows that I
think I think I I don't know I think
just the
thek every step he did here was pretty
swagged out like even just just him
waiting exactly that man is so much
talent it's like you remember in Hunter
Hunter when a netro goes out in the
nature and practices punching yeah and
that's how he ascends to the next level
so I imagine Jose did something similar
where he went out in isolation and just
practice doing this every day yeah days
that's what's the difference frankly so
Jose is a soccer player it's named after
him the dance is named after
him it's a soccer manager soccer manager
but so did he invent the the dance no
they just say they look similar they
like look alike okay it's called that so
he that is his dance
though yeah I don't know what the guy's
name it appears to be that's awesome hey
Gabe what's going on you out in
[Applause]
nature let's say happy Friday baby happy
Friday
love you gab I wonder if gab could try
[Applause]
it go ahead gab have you seen the dance
we're watching the dance I don't think
so no can you see it if I pull it
up Gabe where what are you doing are are
you hiking or are you just hanging out
in your backyard probably in the
backyard right now it's quiet peaceful
no one's bothering me nice
nice it looks peaceful you can see it
now yeah all right I'll show you this
dance I guess we're curious if you can
do it I don't know uh here it is go
ahead wh God gosh dang it God Jiminy
Cricket
man all right here it is okay he does a
countdown so you know when it's
coming here it is three two
one boom where you at where you at where
are you at boom boom
boom what do you
think it's awesome baby it's
awesome Gabe this is our last show of
the year in the office we're do and of
course we'll see you on Sunday
[Applause]
right we'll see you on Sunday I love I
love you and I'm I'm preparing to do
push-ups for on Sunday baby I'm
preparing to do my push-ups baby unless
you want me to do push-ups for the the
show I I could do my push-ups on the
show what do we what what what's with
the push-ups I don't understand getting
in shape baby oh okay just because
you're
train you can do them before the show
that' be fine all right or after or
after yeah if I see Jimmy Lee on the
show he better not disrespect me baby
all the Itali love me baby yeah
you're the king of you're the king of uh
New Jersey
I'm the king of New Jersey you know it
baby yeah Jim better not disrespect me
cuz all the Italians love me and besides
New York tap water is the best baby yeah
oh it is the best okay Gabe why do you
say that you're La you're an LA uh you
live in you're Los angelin what's the
deal Los Angel because what every time I
drink cap water in New York or I have
have water in the
I don't think
water yeah I agree that La tap water
tastes nasty but Zach won't take me up
on my offer he's not feeling that
confident yeah I got something to say
cause santa wants to santa wants to
s wants to
Santa Santa what does Santa want to
do what position are we dealing
with Santa what the all right I
don't want to play I don't can't I don't
play too many of those oh yeah but uh
Gabe anyway we look really looking
forward to seeing you on Sunday we'll be
gone for 3 weeks but we'll be back and
then we'll we'll all be United again in
uh together again in January end of
January mid of January yep I love you I
love you Ethan I love you buddy I really
do how's
business picking up yeah
Christmas yeah I I I always love to plug
your cam
um Gabe is on Cameo and he does a great
job there for anyone who he
delivers the man delivers it's a great
uh stalking stuffer isn't
it
yeah all
right
well nice catching up with
[Music]
you appreciate you calling
in
all right buddy
well thanks for
calling see you on
Sunday all right we'll see you on Sunday
for real look forward to it okay it's of
course to Sunday baby bye Gabriel love
you bud and Ethan I have I have a new
shirt for you bring it to you oh fun I
look forward to that thank
you thanks all right all right love you
dude I love you Friday baby Friday
baby sorry did I wake up the dog yeah oh
show The Puppy Cam
sorry oh Gabe you can see the doggy
yeah little
docko all right bye Gabe did I did I say
that he took a fat diarrhea in our bed
did I tell that
yeah it was so nasty it was so nasty it
wasn't his fault knew better than that
but honestly it was it was so not his
fault because he was having diarrhea for
some reason and he can't get off the bed
and yeah we knew better you're right
you're right we did know better it was
totally not it was 1,00% not his fault
he's just so cute but he's been really
good with the potty training already I'm
really impressed with how fast he's he's
yeah he's catching it I just I feel like
I learned so much from training Shredder
yeah like I know what it looks like now
when he's like looking to poop for
example
or yeah totally 100% yeah and I mean
because they have they're the same breed
there is a lot of like similar
mannerisms and stuff mhm yeah and
trainer Shredder was hard cuz that was
our first time and he was dude Shredder
he would not be okay like this no dude
Shredder from day one was such a punk
dude like he wouldn't eat his food he
would he was even starving himself from
the when he was a puppy cuz he like this
little puppy syrup he just wanted us to
feed him that like puppy candy oh man
and he would go on food strikes even as
a newborn yep and this dog uh ducky he
devours his food he
just which I love mhm because Fe trying
to feed Shredder was one of like the
biggest pressure points in my life on
aily it really was it was a stressful
thing and then Alfredo kind of took
after Shredder in the food thing because
I don't know Shredder made it weird for
alfredo shre I think Alfredo has a
eating disorder now
too but I mean he's healthy obviously
yeah he eats I think he just kind of
like eats when nobody's looking that
yeah that's what I used to
do but um oh he's doing it
again me see ducky show them you so
funny dude goofy that is so Sil oh my
God his body is so like he's so small
and um frag or so small and like Not
Fragile but he's he's just like a piece
of soft
rubber like his body is just
so stretchy and movie you know what I
mean he's so small I think he weighs
like 3 and a half lbs right now or
something yeah three lb that's so
little
but
anyway I
digress we were talking about the
dancing guy and he ran away with the
show here's a little fidus update we're
going to get to the PowerPoint but these
are all important and this is my last
opportunity to talk about them so I do
need to get to it and by the way if you
guys want lunch we should do it now
because oh yeah we're not going to stay
uh super late
tonight what are we fidus friend of the
show great thinker of our time some have
comp compared him to Plato or Socrates
of the modern day I personally think
he's more of an Isaac Newton character
um the with the way he perceives the
world regardless he's doing a 30 days in
VR social experiment and here is a clip
of him discussing his favorite actress
Margot
Robbie this shocked me I I I agree my
jaw dropped I thought it was just some
fun more new mumbling whatever and I was
kind of enjoying the start but then that
hits I was like damn I was like whoa I I
don't I feel like I don't know who this
guy is right well here's the first part
list hear
Barbie
actor
actress Margo Robi bro I want to
this that that blew
me I was like excuse
me oh oh my God
that's so vulgar bro why did you say
that that's like nuts what everything
changed I feel yeah I felt like I don't
know him anymore but anyway go
on oh you got to grab that Zach I pulled
the whole thing I want to that
that was a bit nasty I
apologize oh he immediately
he
that's his inner monologue though wow I
want to that
Jesus man yeah he's so pretty guys
she is so beautiful R tracking like let
me show you some pictures of here I
can't see are am I supposed to be able
to see what he sees no so he says let me
show you he's just looking at them okay
go and find some pictures of here she's
absolutely beautiful like it's just
be just
like watching her face bro she's
amazing maybe he has a chat on in there
and he could send links potentially oh
okay yeah he could even pull up things
in OBS maybe this would be a lot better
if we could see what he's looking at
maybe does he have a secondary stream
where you're seeing his VR view or
something maybe that that is what's
missing in this why nobody's watching
this cuz like I don't know what
you're seeing brother I want to
this bch dude that Jesus that is
so so wrong Fus you cannot talk that so
that was a bit
nasty it was it was I want to this
so
sexy W Robie Marco
Robie let me see what the chat is saying
we going to oh oh
oh there it is wow new F yeah uh clip I
want to this Jus chill that
was a I have a little bit of breaking
news that you might uh find interesting
here Ethan go ahead
news Rudy Giuliani 30 minutes ago lost
his court he has ordered he owes almost
$150 million to Georgia pole work why
does he owe money to pole work uh the
poers who sued him for defamation uh
after he falsely accused them of helping
steal the election for Donald Trump God
the pole workers as a as a monolith uh
sued him for defamation I didn't know
you could do that I knew that he was
being sued in relation to that uh I I
don't know let's see these numbers that
they put out there are kind of dumb like
he's not like let's put out something
like real bunch of P well he certainly
doesn't have that much money not even
Club yeah like let's let's give him like
a real thing 150 million that's
not like nobody has that much money
almost nobody it's the same thing with
Alex Jones they're like one they're like
10 billion it's like see nobody has that
kind of
money uh here's how the jury uh got to
the number deciding the uh case Ruby
Freeman was awarded 16 million for
damage done to her reputation her
daughter was awarded almost 17 million
for damage Jesus Christ each woman was
awarded 20 million for the emotional
distress caused by defamation finally
jul was 75 million impi damages
for that's nuts so but now I
just wonder like cuz he he has nowhere
near that I'd be surprised if he has a
million dollars at this point because he
is desperate and just so yeah um
so like what happens now you know what I
mean yeah is it like a payment plan for
life definitely well and he'll prob a
peel this a million times it'll probably
take years for any actual movement on it
that's pretty that's true it would they
would just garnish garnish his wages
they when that they can take money from
your bank account even if they don't get
the money it kind of sets a scary
precedent for other people it's good
that do not do that I agree it's good
that they won yeah I just
find it's some it just makes it feel a
little silly sometimes when the amount
is so stupidly big that it's like who
who nobody has that much money damaging
this woman costs caused her $60 million
and damages I mean I don't know
the I don't know the details I don't
either yeah that's the jury knows the
details and they're the ones that or the
judge maybe in this case I don't know
but yeah he's never forget this
he's Harris for men is going to be out
of the budget man disgusting after that
verdict where were you when this
happened what an image mhm golly my God
Trump ruined his life
man and like for what dude look at you
you pathetic fool you you tul you Pawn
look at what it got you look what it got
you man $150 million you owe now you're
and you know what you deserve
every thing coming your way you
loser somebody in the chat just
said Google Rudy giuliani's lawyer's
haircut you guys are not tough okay I
will do that okay look at your look at
you man you didn't have to do any of
this you could have just interesting uh
eye caller there it looks like cataract
like oh yeah probably yeah it's a nice
it's a beautiful color though definitely
a nice Hazel yeah for sure he would
probably be ruling
class but like he could have just not
ever done any of this how easy would
that have been if you're just like no
thanks you know you could have done
commentary on Fox probably got paid a
couple hundred thousand a year MH but
now look at what's become of you
man look at you this is you guys are not
so close I can see little hairs this is
incredibly detailed my God you don't
find pictures this detailed y why is it
so detailed look at everything good
camera man like pools of sweat in his
pores are very visible dude look at
everything this is pretty I don't know
about looking at this wait no way hey
hold on the hair Dy is highlighting the
this should not be available to us in
such a
detail wow what a great camera
impressive it's really something yikes I
you see every
po that's crazy so foul all right I'm
trying to find a better picture but I
did find one and I I assume this is the
person they're talking about I'm trying
to find a better angle here Emma said
I'm literally eating this is
sick I know it is sorry this is we have
to we can't look away people we have to
look at what's
happening um I can't see his haircut
though if that it doesn't look crazy I
mean it just looks like a normal haircut
from that perspective well it looks like
it it stops about
halfway through his head I'm trying to
find a different angle but this is
looking kind of wild looks intriguing if
you guys want to help support
him you can at uh use code
Rudy wait he never even said the URL
great products at reasonable prices oh
at mypillow.com use code Rudy new
sandals guys $50 regular price was 80 so
we're seeing slash slash slash those
prices $30 off when do you ever get that
deal never Rudy guys code
Rudy thank
you thank you if there's one person we
didn't need a closeup of definitely our
boy um one more to the we really uh we
really need to do this PowerPoint we're
going to run out of time well I have one
more thing
okay uh but actually we can skip this
one
so we'll wait for ELA to come back I
guess right uh sure I'm ready for it we
got a bunch of uh donos I can read in
the meantime yeah uh are these new ones
that are in the the Dono Channel okay I
can p them in the main
shat uh heyo Barry says hey yo been
watching for years I'm so glad to
finally be a member thank you guys for
making me feel less lonely big he fellas
this is what we got going on over here
hey hey fellas fellas God uh let's see
Serge donated uh
$23.99 and said the last Studio show of
the Year thank you for all the content
please greet uh kie and Kika
love cookie and Kik I think I'm saying
those right thege The Surge Dan is it
the surge uh well it's s e RG serg serg
from system of it now uh no I'm not
spelled the same I don't think uh let's
see uh what else we got here $50 one oh
I'll get that one next uh $50 one here
life is looking mucho gusto glum right
now and my happiest moments are chilling
hot with the H3 crew let's go Ethan
please make my year and hit me with the
keep on pushing Kyla Jenny love y'all
keep on pushing Ky Kylie Jenny uhhuh
does she have a sound or uh Kyla uh Kyla
Jean it's Kyla Jean keep going Kylie
Jenner she wants me to say keep on
pushing keep pushing keep going is she
giving
birth I don't know oh keep pushing keep
on pushing girl you got this pushing
you're pushing
it and there's a $100 Dono here from uh
nerdy sad uh saying I lost both of my
parents last year and watching the show
sad gave me something to look forward to
that I knew it would make me laugh even
on the hard days uh thanks for another
great year and you guys are amazing I
hope everybody has a happy holidays
peace and love thank you so much sorry
for your loss and glad we could uh we
could give you some comfort when you're
feeling when you're feeling down yeah
which it's almost like they're when you
watch this show it's almost like you
know they're alive
again
like
nothing J I don't know if I quite caught
that but Zach Zach is I was just doing a
stupid joke I was trying to be silly
trying to make light I was trying to
make light of a terrible situation dark
as I thought I heard ducky cry I
said no Zach laughing but I almost hit
the button cuz there's crickets out here
person that uh I lost my parent both my
parents in your show you know comforts
me and I said it's almost like they're
both alive
again okay that's yeah I didn't say like
I said almost like it's almost as good
as having your parents back alive Jesus
that's really sad what the hell I'm just
trying my best out here you guys you
know it's a it's a very it's it's
horrible as you can imagine but we do
that we we we we offer that service to
even the what the most
I appreciate it what happened to the
parents that wasn't included no that
info was not
included but you know when when I get
these really dramatic uh messages you
got to hit it with some levity you know
what I mean yeah somebody said great
joke very British thank you what was
going for British humor there that is
exactly what I was going for somebody
said oh brother that's how I'm feeling
oh brother it's not that bad is a good
joke I guarantee whoever left that
comment is laughing they understand I
hope so I hope so they're they are I'm
sure of it if not you can charge back
the money doesn't bother me it's
YouTube's
problem I encourage everybody to charge
back I just don't you know what I mean
just charge back
guys keep your money please maybe they
will um it might be fraud I don't know
but uh a $50 donation from Undead mummy
which was the person that made the stop
oh we love you oh my God the requested
collab with bees from space is out God
bless right uh maybe that was sent
before we uh watched it and they were
trying to bring some attention to it um
thank for the donation you shouldn't be
sending us money though Undead mommy no
you said it in your video you don't have
a job charge it back bro charge it back
please which is Criminal but thank you
again that it was incredible charge it
back such a
dude I love that video I would watch a
whole movie was so emotional for me and
honestly really moving and beautiful I
really loved it really
did all right we got something else or
should we do the the pp
big p
py thank you I got my whole family on
M.R the whole thing so um serious
question are we ordering food or not
because we we we need to yeah it will
be well nobody's taking the nobody's
taking the initiative on this one so I
guess I mean I can't do it what are you
craving I think that's the whole up I I
don't want to do the whole hubbub just
if you guys do want just just decide and
tell me what you guys want otherwise
otherwise I'll decide we can we can yeah
send send options we can that's fine you
know I'm
hearing all right decision's been made
all right so let's get to the power
let's do it Matt rif literally F you
like what the f is wrong with you bud
that is the name of the
PowerPoint next
slide God look at his face he's so
plastic surgeri up literally M
yeah picture bro looks like really see
it he looks like
that Jesus man and I guess you know
whatever plastic surgery God bless do
what you need to does he deny that he
has plastic surgery though or is he yes
he does deny it he says he's only had
his teeth done bro stop there was a
there was a plastic surgeon who made a
like uh a video saying that he gave
someone like the best chin plant in
Hollywood and then he immediately got
cancelled and people were speculating it
was Matt and supposedly Matt responded
to that he did he comment that was so
embarrassing for him he left the comment
being like I'm pretty sure that uh
revealing a patient's info is illegal
Doc and I was like he did not say your
name you're the idiot that volunteer
that he thinks that he has the nicest
chin in Hollywood so everyone will know
it's him although to be fair as a doctor
that is definitely out of pocket super
unethical especially if he's like a
Hollywood Doctor Who's going to want to
go to
him you're a doctor man you're that's
like you violated his hipat what's next
you going to start stripping for us in
the uh conference
room I mean come on man get your
together doctor act like it we we we
expect our doctors to be pure
professionals I don't like when they try
to get silly and they're like you want
some teeth like our our doctors
need to be all busy yeah I agree do not
like I don't want my my doctor making
jokes no no small talk no what
about your dentist or Tik toks I don't
want doctor tick
TOS except for Dr IDs right right
resident Tik Tok doctor you're a guy who
is on Tik Tok that you love he listen he
presents himself in a professional
manner he's serious he does it as a he
speaks as a doctor right okay he's not
out there being like shout out to the
fat who uh I was measuring their I
was observing their diet shout out to
that big fatty it's like no yeah that
would be pretty that'd be crazy to right
damn I as hot as Matt R thought he's not
that hot my life would be so much better
I feel like I don't understand this
whole thing where it's like oh everyone
just likes him cuz he's hot it's like
this guy you know he made that narrative
he's he's a handsome guy but he did
make's handsome yeah he's handsome but
like his face this picture is not
great
is
not everything right it's not yeah for a
guy who talks about how he gives
everything he's not really giving
everything and again we love everyone
how they look we we we love looks we
love looks of all types and um but he
again he's the guy that goes I'm Mr
Handsome he's even said said
unironically of him be like you know as
a handsome dude people think that it's
so easy to do comedy for me I was like
what the did you just say say
there's nothing funnier than being like
I'm handsome like unironically that's
just corny you know if you're actually
good-look just to ignore that bro
you don't bring it up you know just be
happy and don't pretend like it's a
downfall that's so embarrassing use your
pretty privilege if you have it and you
clearly think you
do embarrassing is the best word to
describe Matt rif and it's incredible
The Arc because I went from apathetic to
basically maybe even almost liking him
thinking like he's pretty talented to
being like this is the most embarrassing
man yeah just in Hollywood if you could
even say he's in Hollywood I don't know
but anyway let's go okay so if you go
back I'll just explain really quickly
who everybody is we know Matt R Brook
scoffield is um Tana's best friend and
podcast co-host um we know who Tana Mojo
is next real quick is broo the one we
saw at that restaurant that one time yes
yes she is okay yes we also met Brooke
and tana at the streamy okay right right
right right did I meet Brooke yes you
did oh is she so she's a friend of the
show yeah I mean we walked we got
sliders for a second oh we had a slide
you guys shared a slider moment yeah
well you and Tanner were talking we just
got came back love you girl we're on
your side oh big time on your side all
day all day all day and I don't watch
their podcast a lot but she's like this
super nice oh I watch incredibly nice
super kind grants people a lot of Grace
what's her deal she has a podcast with T
is she a comedian is she she's hilarious
she's funny yeah just to make it even
worse you know she's this super nice
person
yeah how did they end up together do we
know who tana and Brooke oh that story
is I don't know how they met met they
were like through friends but Tana
dropped a story time on her like years
ago when uh they had like a little fight
they both were interested in the same
guy they like hooked up with the same
guy and people found her I remember
watching it and like I was curious I was
like who is it um but they found her and
yeah and then they became besties again
and everybody like knows that story the
origin story interesting this is the
most obnoxious photo like look at his
face I can't stop like bro chill what
the
man anyway go on okay so a quick brief
about Matt re in case anybody in the
audience doesn't know he's the worst um
he came out with a comedy special last
week in it he made fun of domestic
violence survivors then um on top of
that he posted on his Instagram story
saying if you were offended by that
click this link and it linked to special
needs helmets then he beefed with a
six-year-old and told the six-year-old
that his mom who does not have an only
fans which there's nothing wrong with
that but he was like your mom only makes
money from only fans so well the fact
that she doesn't makes it even like more
like what the bro like all women
have only fans who are successful on is
like it's just weird this this beefing
with the 8-year-old as is nuts or
six-year-old sorry six the six-year-old
by the way we've talked about this uh on
the show the six-year-old was right yeah
Saturn is the ring with was the planet
with rings you can't go back and be like
oh yeah well uh you know uh Jupiter also
has rings yeah so what this not
the ring planet you know it's not the
kid's right dude you were you used the
wrong planet
you could probably say any planet
has a ring I mean you know Earth
probably has a ring of asteroids you
know we calling it a ring planet does
Earth have a ring Google that I bet
it does uh it doesn't are you sure yeah
did you Google it
no okay you're
right so let me it has a art probably an
artificial ring of satellites maybe you
could really really really really want
to stretch the
definition here it is sat here this just
is my first thing from nasa.gov maybe
you've heard of them Saturn is a funnyl
looking Planet true it's not the only
planet with rings Jupiter Uranus and
Neptune have rings too but Saturn's ring
are the biggest and brightest so if
you're making a joke about Rings hello
it's right there sat right
thereat dumbass the kid had a point
definitely great point he many points
also the kid he has like a hobby he's
like a he's into astronomy and stuff so
like you can trust him yeah dude kids
know all that yeah so anyway he's
had a rough uh he's had a rough past few
weeks of being a douche So speaking of
the canceled podcast last week talked
about his cancellation dude that
thumbnail is so good it looks like he's
there yes it does that's awesome and uh
so they were talking about his
cancellation and they got a little bit
of heat because they were kind of
Defending in him they were like we know
him in real life they were they weren't
going as hard as the internet wanted and
so they got a lot of flack for that and
so thus brought about Brook telling the
story of her relationship with Matt R
because she she didn't want Tana
especially was like I don't want anyone
to think that I'm a Matt R apologist cuz
I hate him cuz he sucks and he
was the worst to my best friend so like
yeah this episode was was big
everybody go leave your leave like love
for them slay um okay so Brook reveals
she'd been talking about on the podcast
they have like names code names for guys
that they're seeing or friends that they
have and so his name was Mr DC I have to
go back and watch it now knowing who it
is but um why Mr DC do we know yes he
would he would always say like we're
going to run away to DC together like
that was his thing DC yeah I don't know
but um so the way it went down was they
were together at the beginning of last
year um it wasn't no no no stay there um
it wasn't serious uh or it they weren't
boyfriend girlfriend but apparently
Brooke says that he did not want her
seeing other people so it it was more
than just hooking up but they weren't
exclusive um Brooke would travel for his
shows she would like go across the
country to see him and then once he was
done with tour she explained that he
came home and like wasn't
really like hitting her up he wasn't as
like into it and she just felt like a
little bit embarrassed by that and so
she stuck up for herself and she was
like Hey you're not giving me enough
attention like it's not it's not really
fair and he politely told her like I'm
too busy right now and that's how their
relationship had ended so they were a
couple yes they were dating yeah he
comes back he doesn't have time for her
when he comes back he's not not he's
barely talking to her not enough to be
in a relation and their neighbors so he
could have easily seen that's really
awkward yeah and but then he you said he
politely tells her yes she does say that
um she felt good about it okay which is
fair it's like sorry I'm just I'm so
busy you know that's fair okay so moving
on that seems fine everything is fine
everything's fine everything's fine so
the too busy is a yellow flag but we
found out it's a red flag because after
they broke up he got a girlfriend so he
was not too busy m
um next well hold on unpack that well he
said I don't have any time to dedicate
to a girl and then he did like right
after he started dating someone yeah
he's he's with someone right now same
person yeah he's been with the same
person since well we don't
know I don't want to get there yet but
he dat he started dating this girl very
soon after Brooke and very soon after
other girls too um I think I don't want
to give a definite maybe like a month
two a month yeah things can clear up in
a month or two things could you know
true they could they could I'm just
trying you know I'm trying to give
everyone but he wanted to run away to DC
yeah that's that's a big difference I
don't get to run away to DC I don't
think they're running away to DC nobody
runs away to DC everyone runs away
nobody wants to be there everyone's
running away run yeah from Congress
let's see planning on doing storming
Congress yeah you freak running
to DC Jesus man background check
literally so exhibit B okay this is the
craziest thing I have ever heard so
there's this podcast it has since been
like totally taken off the internet you
couldn't find a clip no he like
completely wiped it after people
obviously got mad at him for saying this
he went on stiff socks
podcast and he was asked what this is
just the first offense not even that bad
he was asked what's your type he was oh
I saw that hold on we got to be able to
find that clip it's wiped I really did
look there dude we there this is the
internet we got I saw it it was making
its rounds it's got to be on Tik Tok or
Instagram reals or something like that
those are hard to enforce maybe a Ab and
yeah someone look for that look for I'll
explain what happened so they were
dating at the time that he went on this
podcast they were together the night
before he's asked what's your uh what's
your type he it's totally fine he says
fake tits and blonde hair which Brooke
is like I thought that that was weird
just because I have brown hair and like
I don't have fake tits but like it's
just she she said you know what that's
okay then he goes on to articulate that
a vagina that makes him feel disgusted
and he explained pretty much her Anatomy
which is like 90% of girls have he said
this yeah he
said girls without vaginas are
disgusting they what he and he was like
really super mean about it they look
like God left the tag on them what I
don't know what that
means yeah oh my God anyway it was
really gross and soting so yeah Brooke
describes super misogynistic like really
nasty you imagine it's actually
me it's not even it's like Mega misogyny
is like gross bro that's
disgusting and has this dude ever been
with a girl I that's one of like the
most common insecurities from girls is
like sorry especially because in in like
porn videos everybody's got their stuff
all pretty cuz you know there's
surgeries you can do apparently that's I
dude that blows my mind there's
surgeries I guess that porn stars do
where they remove the yeah so it'd make
extra um people with
natural we found it feel very
insecure
we found it
though so here he is he's really vile
when you talking here you see like yo
that's pretty close yeah like am I
supposed to you or thumb wrestle
like I don't know I mean both honestly I
don't I don't love I don't love a giant
I don't want I don't
want got stop he's talking about giant
clits make him disgusted too like bro
just go dudes then I don't what to
tell you man disgusting can you check
Discord real quick
Ethan yeah
oh yeah we can say that okay yeah just
cuz the the other one yeah yeah
um you guys were saying has a clip
should we watch hers I I don't think it
was just somebody in chat when you were
looking to find it if he tries to remove
it I'm game you know what I mean that's
was saying that he he's like he gets it
wiped Matt please come you know what I
mean come for me I love that that's
what I live
for so I'm going to watch the
clip and you're not going to do
about it dumb ass like yo that's
pretty close yeah like what am I
supposed to you or thumb wrestle
like I don't know I mean both honestly
what the hell I don't I don't love I
don't love a giant clip I don't want I
don't want I don't want to look down and
feel like like like God left the tag on
you I just don't want your to look
like the gum from uh uh sausage party
you know what I mean
you dude that's disgusting to say that
on camera it's it's not funny it's just
super mean it's so mean oh my God yeah
it's really gross he up he oh
okay girl go off we love
you literally so and then she broke
that's her name yeah she
said bravely she admit uh I'm sure it
was it's embarrassing to talk about for
her but she said I have an Audi Queen
wear it proudly your beauty but can you
imagine that
like they were together the night before
and then he goes I hate nasty aiag
unbelievable absolutely disgusting this
guy's dead to
me dead to me dead to me yeah it's
psycho Behavior this is worse than
anything else he's done so far or
said
so next at this point he goes on the
canceled podcast and he and Brooke
um I don't know like where in their
relationship this is but this is after
the stiff socks p uh podcast and tana
explained in the most recent episode
that she wanted to grill him so badly
but Brooke was like no it's fine and um
so when he went on he pretended like he
had never met Brooke ever like he was so
cold he like yes and she explains like I
did not understand why he was looking at
me like he had never met me in my life
and like she got so much for that
episode people were like Brook is being
such a like so mean and cold toward Matt
it was actually because they were dating
and he just refused to acknowledge that
but they were dating at the time he came
on I'm not positive if they had broken
up or if um sounds whatever it was they
were on good terms because they ended
when she felt good about it so either
way so he it sounds to me like they
weren't dating at the time guess a
bit what happened someone say something
never mind what were you going to say
love I I my understanding was that he
like shook her hand I was looking for
and I think I I looked for it they
didn't say that maybe they they did say
it they said he introduced but I
couldn't find that what a weirdo so that
was off camera who was pretending like
he didn't know her no I'm sure he he was
it was on camera so then can we find the
clip of him shaking her hand okay maybe
that I know I looked for it I I watched
the Pod I don't know
um exhibit D are we ready for exhibit D
yeah okay exhibit D this is uh last week
so this is after um his cancellation she
was on Tik Tok and she saw this
slideshow that someone had made of uh
Matt re and some girl not his girlfriend
that he has now and broo was like huh
she was looking through the comments and
she saw the girl in those photos had
commented guys chill out this was the
beginning of the year and Brooke was
like wait I was dating him at the
beginning of the year so she dm'd this
girl and she was like
hey what's up like what what was the
timing like and she immediately put her
into a group chat with other girls he
had dated and they all like had
screenshots that like he he wanted to
take them all the DC the DC literally
like he's going to have to get a bus not
the DC thing DC thing
yeah I don't know this man loves the
capital okay he must have had some
shtick with where he thought it was
funny and romantic or something it's
like some joke about it yeah I guess
yeah that he just he just used the same
line on everybody yeah so there's a
whole Matt r support group formed and
they're about to Charter a bus to DC
Lally if you go to the next line a whole
last
bus exhibit E Yeah so um
exhib uh there were she said that there
were ven diagrams screenshots everything
was the same like pretty much he was
copy and pasting like he had a lot of
time that's he was talking to a lot of
girls dude I hate when that's so gross I
can't people do that where they just
like have five girls and then just Mass
send the same message that's that's like
so C psychotic I'm sure yeah I mean
that's like what the Tinder swindler
type of behavior yeah I mean how little
do you have to care about them to be to
do that it's like really really quite
psychotic the seems to happen a lot with
comedians that are touring dude what
dude I think there's a it seems to me
that a lot of these people who become
comedians do it because of this they
want because they want to sleep with
lots of women Hometown
possibly Matt right well if you're
scared of what 99% of vaginas look like
yeah you're chat you're wrong trying to
waste options he need lots of options
yeah
yeah at least I've seen what a vagina
looks like facts what uh what were you
saying Olivia about Hometown oh someone
in chat said it was his hometown but I
looked up he's from Ohio oh Columbus
Ohio grew up in North Lewisburg Ohio
they me not
love white white
Bo all right okay so exhibit f after all
of this happened and she was put in the
group chat she decided she wanted to
have closure and send him a little thing
just be like hey I just think it's funny
that like I'm defending you and you you
were horrible to me and the message
turned green meaning either he got a new
number or he blocked her number wait
what the am I looking at this is an
iMessage this is not an what happens
when uh you get blocked is the text
bubble will turn green but what's with
the text this is not an eye image is
that a stand is that that's just I from
Google stock I wanted to show you what
it what it looked like okay you made
this just an example yeah so she saw the
bubble turn green I mean he could have
changed his phone it's true or she said
maybe um he like respects his girlfriend
so blocked all those numbers that could
be could be I can see a girl especially
with a tom cat like him and know saying
block block
them okay um and Page Six posted that he
cheated on her with 20 women and Brooke
tweeted out no I that's actually not
what I said so
uh YouTuber Brooke showfield claims xmri
cheated on her with 20 women before
blocking her number and they just made
that
up they like hyperbolized her her story
for sure also they left out the worst
part him going on that podcast was the
most disgusting thing any any boyfriend
has ever done mhm this guy who's like a
Serial cheater and sleeping around a ton
like are you just in horror every time
you have sex yeah like how are how are
you doing that
yeah I hate women bro they're so
nasty so
gross okay um and also guess what little
tidbit he face Tunes his
dickpics wait wait wait wait wait wait
sorry what so he's he's sends dickpics
so they had told a story on the Pod a
few months ago and Brooke was like did
you know hold on somebody sorry
somebody's saying they were not
boyfriend girlfriend Brook said they
weren't
exclusive but they which means that he
didn't cheat on her that's why she's
saying he didn't cheat on me is it
possible they just casual hookups though
no she said no she but they said they
weren't dating so what it's it's a weird
in between thing it sounded pretty
serious not just like I I I don't know
in my mind it's hard to reconcile
serious and
non committed she was on his tour for a
very long time right with him no I don't
know about that I know that she went and
saw his shows she would visit to see him
yeah he's okay I guess not multip I
think we're getting a little sidetracked
I need to hear about this face tuned
dick we need to Circle back to that okay
so they told a story on the podcast a
couple months ago where Brooke was like
did you know that if you have a
photo that you face tune and you save it
from that the file name of the photo
will be like face tune do jpeg or
whatever and so she was looking at at
one of his uh
prizes that he sent her and it said
facetune do jpeg or whatever I've never
used face is it possible that it's just
he opens the camera and it's loaded up
no you have to open the app yeah yeah
also like go for it girl like dude face
turn that face tune that brother
probably hella good be more slick about
it that's awesome I didn't even think
about something I've never seent a dick
pick in my life
because I mean well we weren't at this
age of we were
pretty but even if I was single and
dating
like I would never put that on like bro
you when you send a
dickpic you're basically showing the
world your like that's that's
what's that's where that's going yeah
because you can never unsend that
dickpick now there now it's out of your
hands mhm you well at least it was
stunning probably he he made it
beautiful tuned up I need a dickpic app
face dick dick tune where it makes it
look a little bigger and a little nicer
but not too much not too much that'd be
sick dude we need a dick tuning app that
could be a good money maker sharks
literally bring it to Shark Tank it's
kind of a good idea Mr Wonderful would
go crazy it she like trims your pubes
it's only yeah only dudes would care
about it because no girl cares about
dickpics I don't think yeah I don't I
don't that's no that's what I understand
of it but yeah but um like I said I've
never I've never experienced it
yeah yeah also funny that he had so much
to say about her vagina you're fixing
yourself up uh yeah your dick is clearly
not uh camera ready not even updated get
that in hair and
makeup
seriously final slide that's awesome
though I love that
detail in conclusion you Matt R
like literally what the is wrong
with you also Brooke you are
perfect
yay he sucks what a journey yeah he
sucks is there any Clips we can watch of
her talking about it or them shaking
hands or anything to supplement the just
want to see what the dynamic looks like
look I I want more I can get the link to
when he was on their pod and uh he was
like pretending not to know her I don't
know where the I don't think there's a
handshake but you can watch
it there it is Matt rif let's get the
vibe how old is he I know he's like or
know he's not that young I did made that
mistake before he's like 28 right yeah I
think he was around 30 from what I
remember yeah 28 that's too old to be
talking like
that that's too
old maybe if you're 18 and you're like
just a dumb stupid teenager you've never
had like sex maybe and you're just like
a you don't know anything about Bor yeah
you exactly but at
28 and especially for somebody who
sleeps around
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah this is Matt when he lines up all
the vaginas in a
row this man R Kelly nobody does
nobody
did it go down for a minute apparently
that happened the other day too where it
just like kind of randomly dropped out
for a minute I'm not sure YouTube is so
like the viewership bouncing
around is super annoying man what happen
it it it jumps like between
10,000 difference in viewers constantly
jumping around like fix your guys
it is what it is it is what it is yeah
huh I'm looking at um I'm trying to see
if our internet dropped out for a second
or
something see anything I think it is on
the YouTube kind of ging you I'm like
their is shitty that's shitty sorry
folks this from this time stamp Olive
yeah yeah so here cuz you no no no from
the beginning oh from the top okay you
can just like watch her be like what the
okay let's
see
Hello ready did we talk on the show
about how Matt re was trying to come on
our show show a while ago and I didn't
know who he was and I passed I don't
believe we did I think I didn't know
that I think it was after the show we
talked about it he do you have that
email uh Dan um it was we we were trying
to get Theo vau back on and his manager
said uh not right now but what about
Matt re I said
no I was like who the is that I
don't care about Matt R like he looks
like he treats women
poorly so I was the head of the game
yeah mhm I said no no no no no maty boy
not on my show
bucko
no um just so you know Matt I said no to
you you did not say no to
me here it is hello and welcome back to
the cancelled podcast we have the
world's most requested guest today we
really do the most cancelable guest this
is perfect so fitting I'm so excited to
dive into everything sincerely you I
think we could easil get Oprah on the
podcast
that's clearly not true he's very he's
very willing to go on any show I mean I
said no to him by the way I have not
rejected Oprah um nor would I maybe I
would maybe I'll be like why is o what
do I want to talk about Oprah about no
pass about Harvey Weinstein I'll pass on
Oprah that would be the weirdest show
ever
um he was really on top of the world
here yeah really really was possibly is
she even doing TV anymore is she still
working what's she doing what is Oprah
up to she's on billboards all over
Hollywood right now bro I know what
she's doing she's selling um cauliflower
crust pizzas
dude she's changing the
world one cauliflower pizza crust at a
time yeah she posted yesterday for Tina
turneri well yeah Matt R is here and I'm
really hoping you get canceled today and
not me and I'm starting that off like
good luck I wake up every single day
somebody tries to cancel me so AB try
your best thing I feel like every time
you try to go on a podcast or every time
you do go on a podcast like we stupid
talk situation are we allowed to talk
about that um I mean can if you want
what did she say the what she said the
stiff sock situation and he said we can
and then they brush right over it and
they don't even talk about it oh yeah
watch this is a weird moment he looks
after that uh no I hate cancel
culture I don't support anybody who even
believes in culture neither do we in
canel I think it's brilliant nobody's
like I'm Pro cancel culture that person
does not exist um and I I hadn't seen oh
so sorry Dan Dan bra standing I'm taking
the stand like cancel culture happens
when a bunch of likeminded people get
into a frenzy and do everything they can
to ruin somebody's life and everybody
does it
okay so you're not better Matthew
um I hadn't seen this Brooke yesterday
posted a like Photo dump and the last
one was a screenshot of a text that said
Brooke this is MF like Matt R and she
just sent back the helmet
link hold on let's see Brooke is out
here Brooke this is
Mr this man really who even oh he
reached out to her
mhm and she hit him back that maybe was
he trying to be in case she posted this
probably the record it could have been
M.R the rapper yeah oh bum CL said want
the Gimme
head head turn R
gymnastics now the
dead okay love I love her reply that's
so funny yeah and in case the audience
missed the other day that was his story
when he was getting canceled he post
that special needs link he's like for
anyone met at my special and then he
posted this link so she was hitting him
back with his own joke wow
Queen I wonder what he wanted to talk to
her
about yeah that's such a weird message
Brook this is Mr are we sure this isn't
Mitt Romney okay could be could be there
I mean yeah Mr is certainly could be a
whole lot of people that's all he sent
her you see that was 10:00 a.m. and she
replied in the evening hit him she
waited all day that's like it's like
well do you want to say something say
it he probably wants to get on the phone
call he doesn't want to write anything
uh he wants to get on the phone call and
say like yo can we deal with this
because I'm getting a lot of heat you
know we're dogs
right well the fact that he did Reach
Out means he's feeling the heat CU I
don't think this guy actually cares
about anything right Maddy boy telling
me the other day that when they look up
like they were trying to actually look
up like things I've been canceled for
but when they look up Tana canel the
only thing that comes up is the podcast
andad of all my and I didn't I'm not
smart enough to think of that like that
was not convenient accident that's what
I did for my first special only fans I
labeled it only fans because I knew so
many people were Googling if I had an
only fans so it drove all the traffic to
the special that's so smart I I always
wondered why you did that that's so
smart I love to see it yeah I
wasn't smart enough to so they so they
gloss over the whole yeah they don't go
back that's a shame it
is that's a
shame you know what she told her story
and down with Matt R oh we got chocolate
Fine Bros coming through thank God I was
about Fine Bros Fine Bros Fine Bros dude
I can't I and Sons that's even the same
thing Fine Bros well I keep calling them
and Bros yeah you were thinking F Bros
Fine Bros they I was start to have a
pissy fit that they're not bringing
enough
chocolate me too and Suns is back baby
and they've brought us
bags the official but now like Thorn
should we wait to eat it after our food
no we're going to get full on chocolate
you'll probably be hungry again by the
time the food gets here yeah what's the
ETA like 10 years I'll ask Lenny when
she gets back are oh I love
those oh puppy G hey
Freddy ducky stretchy oh he's so sleepy
it's hard to
walk it's hard to walk when I'm sleepy a
this is the cutest thing should we let
him out for a bit free my boy um well
we're about to eat
chocolate oh true keep him locked up
after that lock him up lock them up oh
mama oh my goodness all right I'm just
going to have a couple of these and
we'll pass them around
okay oh hell yeah hooked it the finally
they're
learning hazelnut truffles we got to
feed a lot of mouths here thank you ant
Sons this looks good okay peppermint
coal truffles isn't that what we had
last time I think that's what we had
right that was the one that I was going
crazy about and what's this one this one
is um hazelnut truffle yeah hazelnut
truffles dark
chocolate
[Music]
I'm good I'm not crazy about hazelnut as
a flavor TR like
Nutella doesn't do that much for me
really no I'm kind of withy on that not
the biggest hazelnut fun oh actually
speaking of which I have some big news
oh boy for you go ahead oh today's a
very special day oh boy it's a
holiday it is
National roasted Chestnut day what it
are you serious December
14th hit it or 15th I guess oh wait was
it yesterday hold on that's your Q
Zach oh no did we miss
it oh no I take it back cut the music no
we missed it it was yesterday
oh oh you were yeah right well it's
happy belated chestnuts day happy
belated roasted Chestnut Day to all
those who
celebrate jelly not Jelly pants go ahead
Zach it's not it's not Chestnut D bro oh
my God belated nah bro got
what jeez you're refusing a direct
order I I you're about to go to military
uh M be bro Bring it on Bring it on
[Music]
oh thank
you
[Music]
sh
gorgeous so
beautiful oh these are new oh my God
those are
pretty such a nice presentation every
time so work of art wait did he
including the ones that we like is that
possible there's
more look at that
so you done what a presentation this is
the one that love loves that I've been
trying to get my hands the three Circle
one oh my God that's that's the schores
one yeahor M isn't it good mhm oh yeah
got oh yeah I want to try that one oh
yeah oh yeah dude oh yeah
dude nice so you guys got some
too you guys have so they really hooked
us up this time two boxes they gave us a
bunch thank you Jeff thank you
Mark I appreciate the gesture it means a
lot you know what I mean
mhm cuz I want to bring this
home I'm hooked have I had this one
little
raspberry oh I see oh there's jelly in
this uhoh
you know
what I've become such a um this one's
kind of good chocolate snob now that
when I get adter chocolates I'm like I
agree mid I
agree like but why isn't Ambrose giving
us free
chocolate okay I'm going to try one last
one it's not jelly it's more like
a it is jelly but it's not oh it's the
peanut butter jelly isn't it oh is that
what that is it's good it's this I just
got one of those that's good mhm it's
more more thick yeah not like a jelly
it's not jelly oh those are the ones I
hate when it's like you know it has like
a
mass a gelatinous MK this is more of a
sauce
yeah I understand you the light blue
ones are my favorite oh you serious I
got to try that one they're like dark um
caramel really rich oh my God oh my God
dud he says every time you guys get some
ansons I go to their website to buy some
and they're always sold out they're hard
to get they're hard to get that's crazy
actually so uh if you're flying out to
LA I know uh I've seen a decent amount
of people in chat saying they're coming
to LA to um to come to the live show um
instead of lining up 8 hours in advance
in front of uh the venue they have a
shop here in LA and they always have
them there so this might be your best
chance to get some I clarify we are not
sponsored by them although we should be
no this is a informal relationship here
yeah I we have have the same yeah oh my
I have to put it away because I want to
eat
lunch we got an exclusive oh come
on wait oh there's a no jelly and a
jelly menu H3 family no jelly menu Bon
bonss a selection of our finest jelly
bon bon
mocha oh that's awesome the jelly well
that's going in the trash you know that
about
me so he made it oh okay that's very fun
like the jelly one that's very I did I
did I did you're
right would I rather it be caramel or
something
yes
wow thank you I'm excited we actually
get to bring some home now did you have
one of these Ethan these little these
little Bowls did you try the other one
the black one no I'll try that one that
one is that's my favorite cuz
that one was crazy crazy good that one I
think is my favorite chocolate they make
it's like a
mint let's observe Dan trying
this Dan is grabbing a Zach do you have
a sound bite for this dark colored ball
what sorry do you have a sound for this
sound for what oh putting your balls in
your mouth yeah I got you well you did
the whole thing Dan put it all in his
mouth just one by that's crazy that's
bald he's nodding he's dancing he's
feeling it it's Christmas wait so what
kind of you a wrong these are so good C
The Mint one try it did you try it it's
so good I'm not actually a huge mint
chocolate fan me neither but that's good
me neither so oh you haven't tried that
love try it let's see why so so dark I
would take half a bite Dan's a little
nuts for taking the whole
that's a huge bite hey no judgment put
your balls in my mouth you're right not
right now D that's good nice very
complex poor Alfredo he's he's looking
for uh he's looking for he's looking for
sympathetic you absolutely cannot eat
these chocolates for you
Alfredo very
fun um where were we ducky is up and
chewing on his chew duck up Duck up just
to give everybody
an
what does this mean look at
this Matt reif people also search for
Kate beckin sale what they dated dude
that lady has a problem wait is that
real let's see if that's true G Kate
needs to chill the out cuz she was
dating Pizza Davidson
yeah I
see um Trevor Wallace I guess because
that's the podcast he was on when he
said the nasty stuff that guy I get I
understand why but Kate beckin
cell Matt r
k let's see Matt R's dating history damn
Kate beckin what is she up
to she's really uh robbing the cradle
lately look at them that's like what do
you do is that some mommy issue thing
you think or just a hot a mil situation
it is one of the top categories I mean
what was she
50 yeah she's
50 and that page you just had open said
that she looks really young I thought
said but she's 50 I don't know 50 today
is like holy
smokes but that's a big age Gap it is a
big age Gap
wow wow
wow she dated let's see he he dated her
back when he was doing wild and out that
was when he's like oh wa she was 43 21
that that's a that could be a problem
okay that's gross that's keemstar
that's gross that is keemstar now he's
28 so in my head I was thinking like 50
but 43 21 that's 21 is so young that's
embarrassing yeah yay lady and every
single one says are 21 how many 21 year
olds you think there are in this
town
okay Matt I see you and Kate I see you
now I see what you're up to Kate beckin
sale uh here is another crazy clip of
his actually I saw this recently it's
very good he used to be on um wild and
out and he looks like such a little dark
here this is
pre uh plastic
surgery um m here he is
basically crossing the line big time
with Sandia and
everybody uh freaks out really here is
uh a picture of a
video okay here we
go the entire time did not spit a little
bit one won the game for her team she
turned me down so this I mean he he's
still like goodlooking right yeah I got
to say what he looks better
how well how old is this he's 21 bro
this is when he was 21 yeah yeah he I
know what you're going to say his chin
is still pretty prominent that's what I
was going to say he's already kind of
got that square maybe he maybe he no he
looks natur have a chin like that hold
on hold on hold on I think Jess I guess
I'd have to see it side by side that's
looking pretty cut cuz I feel like
Jesse's teeth really look very different
his teeth are different there's no
question about that yeah and he said you
said that right got his teeth can you
pull up a that like SpongeBob Squidward
interesting sexy Squidward photo of him
Matt all right sexy Squidward everybody
got their yeah actually I mean now that
I'm seeing it here send it so I can open
might enhancement here oh yeah careful
guys um Duck's coming out so careful
with the chocolate Okay ducky Duck's
[Music]
coming stinky you stinky he does this
thing where he Grooms me it's he like
chews on my hair um some of us are
having problems our main Discord chat I
can't enter oh I just had that too sent
me the same thing yeah so pull it up Dan
on your yeah Discord I I'll send you it
in minions uh Dan okay oh yeah I can
pull it up I say the wrong weird this is
an important uh uh well so here is a
photo of him walk this is the one Ethan
wants that's I mean that one's pretty
prominent but yeah let me see the other
one um I'm trying to find it's like my
internet is tripping out hold on we are
having internet issues for her team she
turned me down and talk spit look you're
mixed I want to be
black make I mean here you can see the
the
profile I'm kind of curious what he's
saying
there're just they're trying to do this
thing where they make trying to make
each other laugh I guess I don't know oh
okay he says you're
mixed I'm he said I'm black want to be
let's do
something look you're mix dude this you
cannot be serious yeah I mean this one
is crazy is that a real is crazy is that
an official photo I don't know where did
where did you Source this one from maybe
cuz that looks that looks silly
yeah like if I go back to here I mean
yeah that's giving me the um what's the
other guy that had his chin and then he
looked
wor uh I think it happens unfortunately
somewhat frequently on the show though
yeah I don't know um oh I know you're
talking about the Z Efron yeah Z
Efron Z
Efron Zack got the worst plastic surgery
of uh you know what I think it was from
an accident so I'm not going to say
anything we love really bad body we love
Zack he's beautiful he's hot he's
beautiful he's perfect you appreciate it
Zach and yes I am seeing that Discord is
uh down so it's not on our end stuff on
the floor here
crashing well my thoughts are if he's
the type of dude that edits his dick
piics then there it is I wouldn't be
surprised if he already had a nice chin
and then that's true exactly that's a
really good point actually that's a
wonderful
observation yeah type of Dude to listen
a lot of the times people who are
unhappy with their looks to the point of
you know like wanting to do medical
procedures are are tend to be what from
what I've seen quite usually quite
beautiful or handsome to begin with you
know yeah it's just a body image thing
you know yeah like look at me I'm
busted but I don't care about
getting surgery done because I have
nothing to
prove okay don't don't I'm just being
silly guys don't be so
serious not every you guys don't need to
chat type Ethan you're gorgeous is
you're hot don't type
that cuz I don't want to see
it fishing for compliments all right go
ahead Matt Jesus Christ trying to watch
this you turn me down and I can spit
look you're mixed I want to be black
let's make a
lifestyle spit that water out so I can
get your number
please I didn't touch if you could have
seen my face
when Matt touched is this guy a
YouTuber I don't I don't
recogniz I know and out has had some
YouTubers join the cast so he may be one
of them let me look yes I recogniz yeah
thought their standards were higher than
that thank you it was it was over I'm
like man uh-uh you're not about to do
that that girl got a job on the Disney
chan first of all ask for it by look at
me straight in my soul okay just cuz I
caress a woman's face everybody's going
to freak out what happened to his accent
that's what I want to know he sounds the
same you think he sounds the same yeah I
think so pretty
much but what do you guys think about
the face touching uh controversy spit
that water off so I get your number that
that's that's pretty wild yeah to and
also like first of all she's got wild on
she's done up you can't and then also
you don't even know her I mean there's
just forward isn't it yeah and just
positioning she's sitting down he's
standing up it's just weird yeah that's
super weird should be against the rules
was she dating Tom Holland at the time
because my boy will murder Matt
you this was a long time ago
right Tom Holland now that's a stud bro
you seen him shirtless damn take a like
take a bite off of that is that
Spider-Man yeah right they've been they
date damn right are you late to that
they've been they've been they've been
together for years Dan they I think they
even bought a house together dude oh
yeah yes why are you saying it like that
because I can't believe that you're just
behind on this tremendous cultural me I
guess I didn't know that yeah sorry if
you want to learn more Dan there's a
great podcast episode Jay Shetty
interviewed him oh hell yeah Shetty got
him of course Shetty got him he's the
goat who's shed's manager that's all I
even want to know cuz that guy's making
magic Happ uh God
who else does he answer to am I right
right God's like I command you to buy
this $5,000 Gucci sweater God did just
like in the
Commandments yeah God the best
for think I'll put him back well is
there I don't think yeah I mean he is
wandering everywhere trouble oh don't
get in trouble
ducky over here bud so curious about
everything what's this what's this yeah
pretty much I mean I don't see anything
visible uh yeah what happened with
shredder we're just so freaking paranoid
about everything yeah I feel you sucks
feeling that
way if you could have seen my we saw it
so anyway L Matt
rif got
it l
rif
um what else we got we got Mr Beast D's
Nuts lawsuit sheesh we got oh we got to
do the Bingo one or the the end of the
year predictions let's do that
next I gotta pee first though
okay I do to at the same time yes sir
yes sir we have all right okay um our uh
channel is still missing with all of the
donations so uh let me see if I can just
oh oh wait I still have my uh my
spreadsheet the Super Chat
log uh let's see here we
go doggy
cam doggy she's he's crying a little
give me the doggy cam let see that doggy
doggy oh I'm oh God dang he's crying I
wish you
[Music]
guys it's okay
ducky you're doing good all right let's
see here cam is coming to the rescue
thank
God he's so happy somebody donated 10B
and said Brit here just got off a
10-hour flight for the live show on
Sunday are you guys excited peace and
love yeah we're excited and wow that's
uh that's probably the furthest I've
seen so far of somebody coming out for
the live show get that off of there I
saw that again um well that's cool uh
somebody else donated and said I stopped
by an Sons today and they gave me a free
hat for buying the H3 jelly no jelly set
nice they're so happy to be the H3
official chocolate well okay we maybe
need to step back from the official
thing there is no official relationship
here we this is a casual exchange uh
going on but uh but yes um shout out to
jeffm Mark over at Anon um he's got to
be trolling with the lip smacking right
I'm assuming they're talking about Ethan
there um no that's just the way he is MH
uh Tyra donated $2 and said it was Mr
Beast any uh guesses on what that was in
reference
to sometimes these pass by and you lose
all context well thank you for the $2
Tyra I'm sorry I don't
understand uh this is a question about
Teddy fresh and uh ela's not here so I'm
going to skip that one for now she's oh
she's back uh is there any possibility
of Teddy fresh temporary tattoos oh
there are companies that professionally
make them for adult consumers brand
partnership I
Emoji okay it's an interesting idea yeah
that sounds cool what kind of stuff
would you want in the
tattoos I mean if they like cool
graphics even just the uh the Ted fresh
logo being included with every order or
something a little thing would be a fun
little bonus or something
yeah uh somebody said Matt re looks like
Dennis from o Sunny well apparently they
have the same personality
too
uh Laura says dan I'm trying to buy
Allie's art but I can't find it uh she's
on um she's on Etsy or uh I mean she's
all over the place where can I find her
I her Etsy I linked it the other day
it's Alison McKenzie art here I'll I'll
throw it in the chat for anybody who's
looking for that real quick
Mr uh people are saying Mr Beast because
we're saying who's Mr they're saying Mr
is from Mr
Beast that's that Super Chat you didn't
know what they were referring to
yeah and yes alie's
awesome uh here's let's do like this um
let's do like this let's go through the
predictions okay and then we'll see who
uh who got it
right and then we'll just keep score and
that's how we usually do this
[Music]
right I I guess well it's I'm so
confused by this we have Bingo cards
yeah it's Bingo it's not we didn't bet
on it's just randomized yeah so I don't
understand why you would give me a b
like why would not why wouldn't you just
keep it in the office why would you want
me to bring it home I don't think I ever
took mine I don't even know well I don't
know what you did with your bingo card I
kept mine for the whole year this has
not left my pocket for the past year
that can't be
true but like do you understand the
problem you can't let me keep it if you
want to actually have it at the end of
the
year and Ethan's like I have no
clue I agree yeah in retrospect maybe
that wasn't the best idea but um you
know just just gather them thank you
just gather them in one place and then
bust them out right you I mean to be
fair I didn't know that we needed to
save it so I don't it was never even on
my raadar I mean I I it was explicitly
stated but like the minute the show
ended I just probably was gone
crumbled it up I don't even remember
well it's okay I mean thinking of it not
on purpose so I'll tell you what we have
the list of all of the predictions we
can just go through them and just those
of us who are responsible enough to keep
our Bingo cards we can see if we got a
bingo okay so let's go ahead and see
um what our what our uh topics were mhm
so number one love moves to USA got him
love who's not here but that that's
actually so cool I wasn't sure if this
one was going to happen you know at the
beginning of the year it seemed like
almost like a pipe dream I had that one
on my cards that was pretty I think I
wonder if that was before the time we
really started getting serious about the
Visa probably right I think it was it
must have been cuz I was like there was
in the air but uh yeah we were trying
but at that time cly wasn't guaranteed
at that point yeah no that was before
the Revolution well you made it I did I
made it I made it Ethan gets below 200
lb and Dan has to put mayo on his Dome
wow
checken check check check and I have
that one on my card as well let's
go
[Music]
W Hanan and Ethan kiss oh yeah don't
think that one happened that never
happened mm- there was a simulated kiss
at some point was there not right there
was but that didn't count well because
of the gr it had to be lip to lip yeah
well rip
man cuz I did have that one on my card
too the simulat doesn't count how was
that how no
[Music]
way no way yeah it's an edited kiss it's
not doesn't really count it has to be
real life
Ethan hikes with Philly D we all knew
that one that will never
[Laughter]
happen e in his suit again that wait you
skipped one oh the podcast gets another
strike didn't get it which I guess is
bad for Bingo but it's good for us
button dude that now that's pretty cool
accomplishment
yeah I got to say a whole year without
being reprimanded by YouTube pretty good
for a grown ass man that's the power of
the button baby have you guys ever gone
a whole year in the past you know I
don't know yeah actually I think so okay
not since I've been here until it was
really just last year that it was it
last it was 2022 we had where we got
like multiple strikes 21 you got strikes
too did we the keemstar thing that
was all like such last year
very and then at the end of the
year we got a strike for yeah
video okay never mind we get a lot of
Stripes never
mind but not since the
button oh ducky it's okay buddy all
right ducky he wants to play with
AO look at this guy
ducky oh you don't want to let him
out you guys should wait until after you
eat all right just wait till we're done
duck duck um Ethan is suit again I don't
believe that
happened so I was really trying to think
on that one no no not this year that was
all last year or the year before I guess
it's been going on so long so stupid
yeah yeah but I don't believe I there
was no new lawsuits no well I had that
one on my cards bummer which is also
very good news for me yep yeah I
supposed so you supposed so I mean I'm
trying to get a Bingo here
buddy AB wins his greater Clash fight oh
get I didn't have that on my card
I could have easily won that but not on
my card so sorry guys oh so you didn't
have you didn't have motivation cuz it
wasn't on there oh wow that's crazy that
that was this year yeah I know it was
wait what month was that in that was
April April yeah
wow Dan uses the live delay switch and
saves the podcast I mean definitely has
happened yeah that that's a that's like
obvious yeah I guess we had we
hadn't really used it that much by then
uh I don't think we I think we had just
set it up right at the beginning of the
year yeah yeah I didn't think we
understood how frequently we we would be
using it cuz that's obvious yeah Ethan
and Trisha make
up that did not happen H bummer had that
one drick Pizza shuts down far from no
it's thriving mhm people love D Brick's
Pizza
y ninja apologizes to poke man that's a
weird one what no no love says
nope
thank you for that who's chewing would
you like me to continue while you chew I
got this let's see the crew will attend
gab's next birthday party sadly that did
not happen I thought that was going to
be a Cheo in this year oh my God me too
why you switch your yourself Daran I
have tons of excuses I don't know what
you guys have I didn't even get I didn't
even know anything I wasn't invited
until the day before and again as we
discussed the last time when everybody
got mad at me for not going I never I
didn't RSVP I I was busy that
night why am I like I didn't say I was
going to go and then flake mhm you know
what I mean people got really mad at us
for that and I got to say they told us
the day before not only that but also
the party was started at like it started
at midnight something no it was midnight
Midnight the party started at midnight
yeah oh that's hard that that's pretty
extreme yep yep yeah I was trying to go
with my dad until we realized it was it
started so late what kind of party
starts at midnight what does that even
mean I don't know I was genuinely trying
to prove yeah I don't I was genuinely
excited to go there with my dad it's
because it was after the show Nick Nick
had a show and then it was
after could have done a different
day but okay we love Gabe we did not
attend his birthday party
though I have really good
excuses I was in a different
state mhm I have kids mhm
busy dogs it's
late lazy that was one
under
um AB throws up at least once I think
that happened definitely literally threw
up this morning what what God
uh means I I got the rental truck for
the live show and then um I when I got
here Sam was saying that the couches
were ready so we went to go pick them up
me and Sam and the guy there would not
help us so me and Sam had to lift the
couches and put them in so anyways
loading up the truck and then I like
needed to rush here and I ran up the
stairs I think too fast and it was just
too much and my ass puked really
wow yeah
oh well you have puked on the show too
yeah yeah def
Thanksgiving laugh you lose you puked I
think yeah mhm the spicy chip was that
this
year um
yes you PUK during that as well no that
was last year when AB through was it
yeah we Revisited the spicy chip with uh
love right cuz there was an updated
[Music]
one the spicy chip was last year yeah
yes sir yeah that makes sense I just
finished the uh end of the year video
this show is like destroying my
time my sense of time yeah and then not
in a good way cuz
like I'm just going to
my whole life my whole
beautiful life everything every moment
every day it's just going to disappear
dude one day it's just going to be like
10 years from now I'll be like what
happened
dude what happened but I couldn't be
happier to be here with you
guys it was September 12
2022 wow there you
go do you know what I mean though like
like I feel like the past 5 years have
passed really
fast
[Music]
um yes but
also when you look back it's like a lot
happened
too where were we 5 years ago no kids no
kids which is like to me another
lifetime that's true no kids is crazy
old Studio old preo MH pre PR it's a
long time
that is a long
[Music]
time
um podcast gets news coverage oh did
that happen that may have happened with
maybe with the debates or something y
yeah what coverage did we get a few
[Music]
times he
want he wants to play with you uh let's
see oh did you even see this there's a
article about your C Cav lawsuit from
October of this year no but that counts
the title is really funny Jake Paul
fight lasted 119 seconds H3 podcast
copyright battle hits 124 weeks
somebody's goinging your lawsuit with G
wait hold on pull that up I want to I've
been more
weeks than the number of seconds of the
actual fight
here I'll just sent it to you torrent
freak shout out to the Fine journalist
freak
dude I'm actually really curious about
this what is
this in April
2021 Jake Paul knocked out Ben asken in
less than two minutes Charlye after
popular H podcast declared the fight a
disaster showed a clip of the fight to
back up their claim after being sued by
triller for $50 million in Damages his
she opted for a fair use defense now
it's 124 weeks over a short clip of a
fight that lasted 119 seconds the LA
should be compulsary reading for
YouTubers bro I cannot agree enough like
this lawsuit is one of the dumbest
things you can ever imagine like
one other person they charged for
copyright theft he did not respond to
the uh complaint because he's just some
random dude and the judge ordered him to
pay like just basically the the
pay-per-view amount like like nothing
like negligible amount M and we showed
even less on an unlisted link crazy and
like even if it's insane it's so
dumb
man in our Brave New World where
millions of ordinary people are
copyright holders of that's true of
snaps they published to social media or
videos they upload to Youtube awareness
of copyright law is at an all-time high
evidence is found on Reddit where users
of are copyright and similar Subs
answering questions can I print a
t-shirt with Batman on the front
definitely
not let me answer that for you no can I
steal a highly popularized one most
recognizable characters in the world
yeah probably not you know what blew my
mind that I learned about copyright the
smiley face is a massive company
and they like are yeah Forest Gump
invented I learned that from comp I was
just going to say really I didn't think
it was real though yeah me neither I
didn't I thought a gag right how do you
copy how do you built how do you own a
smiley face two in a line box of
Chocolat is it specifically on a yellow
smiley face though no it's all that
smiley face like they could probably Sue
dream honestly if they wanted to I'm
surprised they
haven't well his is it's a little like
distort it's not really like the normal
iconic smiley face right I'm saying but
but like their copyright is super broad
like let me see smiley face smiley
company that's what it is anything like
this it doesn't even have to be yellow
they own crazy all this
what do you invent a smiley face
you think they have a licensing deal for
emojis yeah I mean the standard smile
Emoji is basically that yeah they
probably had to license it dead serious
huh
yeah anyway weird um similar gems
are regular current on YouTube who
hasn't seen copies of well-known blah
blah blah let's see if there's anything
inter trying to play with alfredo is he
not having it no Alfredo be nice you
wants to just
play ducky is they oh my God ducky is so
sweet he's so
unfaded I'm sorry ducky I don't know why
you said oh
no oh he's trying to chew is that what's
happening maybe oh wait hold on ducky
wants to chew I think they're I think
that's his no yeah but let's get him
hold on ducky hold on ducky hold
on I think it's mostly about playing
though I don't think it's the
CH Tony in the chat said sent H3 podcast
Dan proof of gab's birthday mishap how
you want this do a trade yall are doing
too much you know what I mean yall just
sometimes you just do a little much it
really wasn't a big
deal there you got your own chew now so
cute now they're chewing
together cute so cute puppies are like
the best thing ever aren't they yeah so
H like the Hat ducky it's
there all right
all right where were we uh let's uh we
should get back to the the Bingo cards
cuz we have a lot more of these to get
he's he's honoring our win in
2017 124 weeks of litigation and
[Music]
Counting does a URL and a video
infringement does a URL in a video
infringe copyright yeah that's that's
the big dumb question at the
center of this because the URL was
visible mhm they're suing us for
for for
rebroadcasting to our unlisted
channel right so like e again even if
we're found guilty it's got like 70
views on it the majority of them from
keemstar and uh posting a link
to the URL right so who really broadcast
if that didn't happen they' probably be
like like two to four views on it
yeah anyway whatever thank you to uh we
love you I I I don't have time to read
your thing but we love you seems like a
good write up though
yeah so anyways podcast news coverage
that's a that's a yes right I can get
that one yeah yeah definitely excellent
Hassan Ethan Deb major
conservative that almost happened it
almost did close and I have that
one too well oh yeah not in did that
block my
with with Viv
Viv like cake he right
there um Zach shits himself did not did
not happen this year good year for
Zach's
Keem and Ethan squashed the
beef who added that that's crazy the H
that's like a hell when hell freezes
over type of thing El gets pregnant
again
that oh my God that's crazy that one wow
2.7 million subscribers wait is that up
or down that's down oh so so we we had
both ends of it and really we pretty
much maintain the exact same amount of
subscribers which I'm happy 2 neither
happen that that'd be brutal
man this all trash yeah I'm done thank
you Prince Charles in a box like Lizzy
nah nope he's still
going Joe Biden afterlife no no still
going Kanye Ethan crossover what the
is that no like some sort of like
interaction I think the idea was cuz he
had already started his I'm a neonazi he
was getting close to us right and so it
felt like it might have happened at some
point but no he he's like back this last
week oh just just last night dude just
last night just last night he was
supposed to release an album today
actually and let me guess it didn't come
out I no he was recording stuff at like
400 in the morning for huh um that's the
weirdest thing Nicki Minaj yeah he's
that old saying about the definition of
insanity again keep trying the
same get off Twitter different results
don't really like that saying I never
really found it to be it's like that's
not the definition of insan I know it's
just like there's a lot more to it than
that doing the same thing over and over
again I mean and expecting different
results yeah it's it's just an IDI
persistence baby that well it is in the
case of being a Kanye fan uh kind of
does apply doesn't it in a like the 20th
time that he's done exactly the same I
mean I'm out I'm in it for the spectacle
at this point okay let's see just last
night actually he was hosting a a rave
in uh Las Vegas for $2,000 to get in but
it got shut down cuz they didn't have
permits man a so dumb oh wait I
shouldn't have said that sorry why cuz
you're a mod yeah you want to lose your
status Pete Davidson gets married that
did not happen n Drake faces a major
cancellation that did not
happen significant evidence of alien
life is discovered that got it did not
happen oh definitely unless you include
that Mexico yeah you don't remember the
Mexican alien moment oh that's true I
forgot that you're right that did happen
there it is there it is baby we
confirm oh my God I'm marking it that's
significant evidence to me what about
that Tik Tok video too of like the
backyard remember the backyard video oh
yeah yeah so actually yeah there's
been really compelling evidence this
year did they blur it genitals what's
that red line no they're scanning it and
like
oh um Tesla completely tanks did not
happen Ethan makes another bomb threat
did not happen thank you Wendy Williams
comeback did not happen no still waiting
dad still waiting H3 permaband Jesus we
wouldn't be able to do the show if that
happened well I think we Define that as
being permanently banned from anything
so like if we had had our Tik Tok
account permanently banned that would
have counted or Instagram or whatever
God we'd have to really up to get
Perma banned I feel like well you did
get banned well not the podcast I was
going to say your Twitter got banned for
a little bit but you got that back I
yeah it would have had to have been a
permanent that's true it almost it was
true I thought the Twitter or the Tik
Tok too trying to go next to Alfredo and
Alfredo walks away he's trying to get
the Sho though no he dropped his you see
no he he wants that one he wants that
one yeah he wants that one he ducky
doesn't understand like edate of The
Chew hi ducky well I think it's ducky it
is his you're right but Alfredo he
wasn't using it at the time
yeah oh we're stuck in the little
wire uh Jeff Su David do and
wins why did we have to add that these
predictions are too specific well he
there was a settlement according to that
was there that lawsuit from State Farm
oh
Al I don't know it's it's hard to say oh
my God was that Alfredo a little warning
he's just said back off dude scared me
he snapped he does he he didn't snap it
was just a bark a he was just like back
up there a beautiful snap that's how
that's what he does yeah it's cute how
he like prances when he when he walks
jum like that it's like a little ball
yeah he always runs at Alfredo and jumps
at him it's so cute and Alfredo hates
Alfredo you got a little brother uh oh
one podcast one of the podcast couples
gets a dog you guys oh we did you did I
guess that counts yeah I mean yeah of
course it counts we got a dog people are
saying that Tesla had it this massive
recall which yeah it did but did that
just happen that just Happ it just
happened this week and I we were talking
about this morning I'm like oh I bet
their stock took a hit because like
that's bad 1% up that's huge for a daily
game even if you go to 5 day it's like
it didn't affect year to day it's
totally fine is so disconnected
from reality at this point it is crazy
yeah it makes enough sense how do you on
the on the week that you have to recall
2 million Vehicles your stock goes up
and also like Tesla is having a bunch of
issues in Sweden and all the skandan
count it's just like this is it's so
gamified at this point it has no real
connection to the actual think that
they're I might be speaking at of turn
but I believe that they've become highly
profitable in terms
of yeah no I think in the last couple
years they actually have been turning
pretty big Prof profits so I think
that's probably why the stock is up
because their books are just super super
clean are healthy in that regard there
you go it's like a
easy I think people see it I don't know
if it's one of these stocks that you get
like uh dividends on I know people love
that you probably get a little bit
of
divy money podcast hits 3 million Subs
again that didn't happen s also didn't
happen didn't go up didn't go down
podcast gets national news coverage we
already said that uh so I guess it's
because it's distinct from normal news
coverage versus national news coverage
specific kind of Fox News kind of thing
like right I guess like K KTLA versus
right yeah Fox so I mean I don't I don't
know that we had national no I don't
think so news coverage we had Detroit
Free Press just insane B Shapiro talked
about me or I don't know was that this
year is that National I think that was
last year not really yeah uh Ethan is De
throned as hairline
King I mean my hairline is the same as
it was when the year started
yep what I know you want to say some
go ahead I'm I'm not saying
anything go ahead I know I know what
you're thinking I'm not really saying
anything all right dude you really think
this dude his hairline is so high up and
his hair is just big who I think AB said
that it's an illusion he's just has big
hair and that hairline is like way up
there man that's like the North Pole of
hairlines boy true
inhospitable true nice try great hair he
has beautiful hair hair is great can't
say too much dudee his hair is stunning
by the way both of them do this one yeah
what about this
one click it oh it's just famous
birthdays.com with his hair that long
it's about the size of Ethan's hairline
why is his hair so big bro chill got big
hair big hair
bro link you don't have to make your
hair so big
brother like like at a certain point you
got got to realize
that you're just the big hair
guy have we taken a close look at J
shed's hairline it's he in fact
I've seen it he got this ridiculous cut
watch this I'm growing my hair back
people looks pretty good how old is J
shett how old yeah he is 36 36 he's
younger than me what a
douche look at this hold on where's the
one with the look at this no not
this one looks great I I got a I got one
wait did I just see one of him pulling
it back there's one of him where he
shaved off the widow's peak and it looks
super silly the one I have doesn't have
a Widows Peak I don't know if it's the
one you're yeah this is it look at this
bro bro what are you doing with your
life look at that who lined this man up
why did they cut that damn he's the
double hairline also it's not cleaned up
so it looks silly
yeah
he probably dyes his
scalp he would be that he's so vain you
guys don't even know D his scalp I mean
he definitely has he has color in it
right here you think he colored it I
mean it looks yeah it's so vain bro I
can't say for certain but I think you
might be right like he doesn't have one
single gray hair and there's just like a
little bit streaks on top it looks like
bro you are so vain it's crazy how do
you look at yourself in the morning like
look at you bro oh you know what I found
one with gray so maybe yeah I think
you're right about what I F about him
dying it cuz I I see gray hair is in one
of these photos I'll send it bro I can't
believe you went outside like this with
your with the widows people I think it
looks great I wouldn't I would never
even notice me too I mean I mean well
I'm showing you embarrassing I'm showing
you I don't know why would people want
to cut that out like what's the problem
with the I don't know I agree I don't
know but cuz obviously it's going to
start growing and then you'll see cuz to
pull off this hairstyle Ethan I know I
know you're showing me something but my
eyes are just locked onto his eyes I I
can't oh there we go okay oh yeah I do
see what you mean yeah
okay look through my eyes then you will
leave the podcast join my
crew Ethan
Klein yeah you J shete trying to
steal my
staff
scumbag let's not forget he probably
pays like too no he he's probably
so generous yes he does he's cuz isn't
he friends with DAR I don't think I
don't he probably doesn't take a salary
he probably does it for free yeah giv
gives 100% of everything he's friends
with Darman right yeah he's he's yeah
they're dogs which first of all is
embarrassing second of all birds of a
feather this man pays like have fun
over there at 30,000 a
year and no benefits right
yeah well I can't that is a pretty good
point not going to lie but I mean his
hairline is pretty good for his age but
it's not better than mine no no yeah I
guess not all right so you're still the
hairline King we're we're letting you
have that thank you yep appreciate fine
and you know like I said shout out link
shake out Shout Out J
Shetty but let's be real for a second
you
know look at this humble man
then who would have thought that we
would have turn into this
monster why you grabbing your shoulder
he looks so kind yeah I'm
sure sure he's super nice yeah you know
what I take it back I go work for him
for
free there you
go okay wait there are some actual
pretty incredible contenders I will say
I don't think anyone will beat my
Champion nobody
George Lucas actually is pretty stack he
might be there although he's thin it's
combed in a wayes this but this is
hairline though it's hairline and also
do we not give a handicap for him being
in his like late 70s but okay but we're
going to compare cuz you know what I
mean you got a factor in the age look at
the photo I just dropped though all
right so find him at 38 he's 79 he's
almost 80 years old he is yeah wow he
looks good for 79 holy that means
we need to like prepare ourselves to
lose George in the next decade or two
he's 79 we lost him a long time ago easy
easy man easy yeah he's no I love George
I feel bad Legend his hairline absor
absorbed his
jawline it took the power from
one gave it to the other he has an
iconic jaw
line when he was young uh Circle yeah I
mean here it's probably more fair to
compare this here he is in like his 30s
yeah let me see oh wow what a
hunk D look like he looks like you can
no kind of actually I wish dude I my
hair's I'm going to fully say it right
now my hairline is going away too
brother it's going bye-bye it's going by
not bad though do bro get with the red
light uh
hat right how how old are you cam um 29
yeah I mean mine started to go around
like 28 28 so bye-bye how long did it
take Dan from 20 to basically uh well I
mean the main thing is that you know it
was receding here a decent amount but it
was mostly the the what I call the
yamaka spot that it it balded back here
first and that's as that got worse and
worse that was why I was like you know
what I should just shave it cuz it's
like stupid like that nice good for you
you're Rock The Shave look though oh
thank you thank at this point I
can't we were talking it's was it on the
show we were talking about like the hair
transplant thing and I really was
thinking about it I don't think I'd do
it I kind of yeah I'm kind of locked
into this you rock it I can never Rock a
bald head I did that once and I cannot
do that again well I'm fortunate that I
I don't have like a misshaping head or
something I guess president is also as a
killer hairline oh wow um and another
hairline King David Lynch that yeah his
hair here his hair is gorgeous yeah but
look at the I mean this guy's really has
a beautiful head of
hair you can't trust this guy though
it's like so defined it's true I mean
it's true he's a communist yeah so where
my man's eyebrows he hey fway the other
month so he's he's fine by me he fixed
the t wait I wonder if this is a
wig you think hair system yeah oh it
doesn't match the rest of the it's too
nice yeah he would do that though he's a
Communists
dude they all wear um hair pieces what
it's like way too full at the front too
it looks unnatural to me Vladimir Lennon
never wore
hairpiece because the technology wasn't
there he would
have he'd be walking around with a
beautiful head of hair if he was alive
today gorgeous and then David Lynch of
course we can't forget yeah he's another
king his hair is really truly truly
remarkably nice here he is just un just
from his YouTube
I mean he's got such nice hair hair this
looks almost
unnatural it's real though yeah it is
real it is real cuz he's always had that
yeah dude over the years I don't see
what you could even do to up what
procedure you can even do but when it's
pushed back you see that it's not as
nice as mine you can do a hairline
transplant I mean I'm not saying he did
but like MGK did that this man just for
the record yeah there's old pictures of
MGK like
bald not bald but like hardcore Widows
Peak wow I didn't know that wait but so
this picture really tells a lot of the
story though let's be honest show it
well show it Ian
coward I mean the man is receding all
over the
place I don't know it could also just be
the shape come on cuz I think it's
always been like that look at the other
photos well he's old you got to find I
mean look when when he's young all right
young yeah like this well it's covering
his face let me see David
Lynch
young let's
see what the hell it looks so
different look at this what well
it's all combed forward so it's hard to
tell yeah
but
here he is this kind of interesting
photo of
him it's hard to tell because the way he
Styles his hair yeah but there's no
question he's got a he's got a
great a great head of hair there no
question about it top five I think would
never try to even take that away from
him and he's Brave too even in his old
age to be putting it back like that most
people wouldn't do that it's just lay
they don't have the hood spit like me to
be wearing my hairline out fully
unobstructed you
know I have hairline
privilege all right uh so yes I'm still
the
king um and finally this last one PCAT
tries a d drastically different format
and it works that has not happened yeah
well we talked about it earlier we were
saying see you next Tuesday if it works
that's debatable but it's not
drastically different it's pretty
drastic we have like a smooth running
machine you know over here and then yeah
but okay has it worked though can we say
that it's worked people like
it does it work I mean that's that's
your call that's in the mind that's in
the heart of the
beholder so did anyone get a
bingo no no all right fun well thanks
for playing
everybody
[Music]
fantastic got a bingo Dan
listen uh no it was the Tesla not
tanking that me so you Elon
mus we're almost done well we were
supposed to do 2 hours we have not done
that we have done how long like over 3
hours God damn it I don't know why just
I love you guys too
much I want to put on a fantastic long
meaty show for you
guys but I can't believe it's the last
show of the Year here and the next one
is going to be on Sunday
live boy boy boy
2024 what the
Yeah so with that being said thank you
everybody for joining us
here hope you join us next year for
another fantastic year of shows
surprises laughter love I wonder what
what next year would look like you know
who knows who knows who knows who can
say we don't know we shouldn't speculate
we shouldn't don't even try just don't
die that's what I was going to say like
maybe I get cancer or something I don't
know I don't want to go there I might be
dead for by the end of I might even be
here I was just thinking Brian Johnson
I'm not you're thinking what don't die
like Brian yeah yeah I'll try my best
not to die I mean but that's why I don't
like to be like next year is going to be
this no you might be dead you might not
even be alive dude I do want to be
alive though I want to be there let's
put on the bingo card somebody dies no
that is so up not even that's not
funny I will not allow that I'm not
doing I'm not I'm not Z play the oh
you're already playing never mind not
doing it not funny not doing it right
now all right everybody see you on
Sunday at 700 p.m. love you all have a
great great weekend and uh we'll see you
T
[Music]